uh welcome to House Education uh this
morning we're going to be starting right
off here uh we do have a hearing
scheduled for 9:00 this is a a hearing
dealing with a non- gerain uh Amendment
which is being would be attached to HB
1015 uh we'll get onto that in a few
moments here just to explain what we're
going to be doing this morning uh from
9:00 to 10:00 we have that hearing and
from 10:00 onwards we're going to be uh
delving into structure organizational
Cooperative school districts saus
merging visory boards uh budgeting
within uh apportionment all those uh uh
necessary issues that we need become
familiar with in order to address some
of the bills that are before us and so
that'll go through to about noon time
they'll take a break at we will take
lunch today at 12:00 and come back at 1
I have a meeting with the time
across the street the council this year
uh during that hour and then uh starting
again at 1:00 we will uh address the
afternoon's uh portion of our agenda
today which is dealing with executing
some bills so with that uh we have a lot
going on I like to uh I'm going to be
leaving with representative Miler right
now and going over to the Capitol
Building uh we're going to have
representa uh Pell uh chair uh this
meeting and of course representa
cordelli is going to be presenting uh
the amendment so we're going to take a
moment do the exchange here and then
we'll be on with business thank
you all
right he doesn't have any notes for
so
okay
exactly exactly have a good
morning
all right we will begin the hearing on
House Bill 10:15 relative to
requirements for literacy skill
development in Elementary grades with
the um with an amendment to the the bill
presented by representative
cordelli thank you madam chairman um
thank you fellow committee members um uh
for the record uh Glenn cordelli
representing tuon Borough wolfboro and O
in the beautiful Lakes Region and um
this is a uh non-gain amendment to House
Bill
1015 um but I'd like to begin with the
same quote I began um uh my bill last
year with uh as Frederick Douglas said
once you learn to read you will be free
forever um and and I'd like to thank
representative ball for her um interest
and um experience and passion in
promoting literacy in New Hampshire and
uh uh introducing
1015 um I I think this uh Amendment um
is necessary uh because if New Hampshire
is really going to improve student
reading we need a comprehensive
approach it starts with the early
screening then the intervention when
necessary but we need parental
involvement we need monitoring we need
transparency and
accountability we have to make sure that
current teachers are coming up to speed
with the evidence-based instructional
methods and also very importantly the
teacher prog teacher prep programs have
to be on board with this um new um
instructional method so where do we
stand today
uh the
2023 proficiency level the state average
uh for ELA was
52%
52% uh my district Regional Cooperative
School District with to EXs swep
towns the ELA uh proficiency rate was
51% below the state
average uh two of the towns Effingham
Elementary School reading proficiency is
60% but funny when they get to
elementary school excuse me the Regional
Middle School it drops to
44% so something is going on and and
Corrections are
needed um what I'd like to do is just go
through the amendment uh section by
section U briefly if I could um and it
starts on page
one with uh the uh reading assessment
and intervention section um aligns 10
down through the bottom of the page
really and
um again there would be a screener uh
purchased by the department a
comprehensive uh screening for uh uh
reading and
dyslexia and all the risk factors
therein and has to be done three times a
year um according to um really all the
uh the experts and you'll see listed on
lines 19 through 25 the um predictive
measures that would be screened for um
which in based on the um evidencebased
research that's been done over decades
that is uh referred to as the science of
reading um
this would start the screening would
start 40 days into the school year and
three times a year as I mentioned U but
also as you see it continued on page two
for anyone coming into the school
transferring into the school who hasn't
been um through the screening would have
to be screened so if someone's moving
into the district um we would want them
to be
screened as well
um in Roman
3 um if there is an apparent uh
deficiency
and um documenting the uh deficiency is
required in an individual reading plan
and um the department is to come up with
a form um for that um and we've had U
actually um a national expert uh
volunteer to help help with that
effort um down starting on lines
23 we want to make sure that we're
moving forward we're not maintaining the
status quo so this three queing method
of um reading that is being used widely
um at this point um which includes
visual um cues that that is not being
used in any of the instructional or
Interventional
programs um also the fact that uh
parents have to be involved in this
you'll see that on the bottom part of
the page in that um strategies have to
be given to the parents to how they can
help with the the deficiencies in their
child's reading and they first of all
they must be notified that there is an
issue
um it's critical
that parents are involved in this
process over to page
three
um one difference
um in um this amendment from
10:15 um I I don't lay out any many any
mandatory time frames for referrals uh
for special
education um I'm just um concerned that
um there would be um a slew of uh
referrals possibly and uh I wouldn't
want to see overidentification of
students as requiring special education
either
um the rest of the page really um
outlines um many
responsibilities of the department um in
this effort um already mentioned the
fact that they will have to find the
funds to purchase um this Universal
screener but as you'll see starting in
Romans 7 um they have to provide
periodic workshops to Educators and
parents on this instructional reading
method they have to provide guidance to
the districts on instructional materials
that um are based on this evidence
that's been gathered over the past
several
decades they have to do reporting
uh to the department
um as well as the school districts and
charter schools have to do reporting uh
as
well and the Department's reporting has
to be given to the governor's office
including I think it's important that
the governor's office see uh what's
going on and what progress hopefully is
being made in
this the bottom of the page gets into
the teacher prep program which is um
very very important I think
um and it lays out the requirement to do
a survey of the teacher prep
programs um with
criteria that were was developed by the
uh national teacher quality Council n
tcq um they did uh two years of work
work coming up with these criteria and
they surveyed um uh teacher prep
programs around the
country um to see if they were meeting
um the uh criteria that uh the NT CQ
came up with um I'll just mention um the
four New Hampshire colleges that
submitted um their um results um to the
uh to the council
uh Keen State got a B Plymouth State got
a D Southern New Hampshire University
got an F you and H got a
D so
work needs to be done in the teacher
prep programs if any progress is going
to be
sustained uh for our children in in
Reading
literacy the next section um of the uh
Amendment um starting on line nine on
page three um are reading Improvement
Grants um these would be grants to um
districts or elementary schools that are
in the uh below the state average in
Reading
proficiency
um I I've talked with the chair of
Finance
um about um appropriation for these um
grants and um um we he says that uh if
the bill comes to finance they'll work
on finding the
funding um and the department would be
involved in looking at plans submitted
by the districts in terms of how the
funds would be used uh to um improve um
literacy in their
schools uh the next section on the
bottom of the page um modifies current
Statute in terms of literac literacy
School skill
development and includes the fact that
we want to move to this uh
evidence-based instructional methods and
outlines um at the bottom five or six
sentences of this page um the components
of reading literacy that we'll be um
interested in and um you can see that um
I've borrowed from the original 1015 and
added writing um in there as well as all
the other components
um in that
section so those are really the the key
components of this um
Amendment um and I I think that it it
really identifies a um comprehensive
approach um I've worked with uh people
around the State national experts um as
well as the department and and I see uh
director white here um but um it's I I
even sat in on a professional
development uh session um in London
Derry this summer um with teachers um
going over uh presenter talking about
moving to um the science of reading and
um uh it was uh very interesting uh
being the only non- educator um in the
room um but
uh they are all interested in in doing
this um some of the schools were already
doing it um many weren't and so um uh
there is the interest in doing it and I
think that what I've tried to lay out
here also will help
teachers um and Educators in moving uh
to
evidence based uh research and
instruction um and we we've talked in
the past about some of the research um
you know we've talked about
uh
yeah the reading brain
and the detailed efforts to even
identify um parts of the brain and what
happens um when students are learning to
read and the difference with dyslexia
also when student has
dyslexia um how it works differently in
the brain so we want to take advantage
of this research we know that um we know
that it work works from results around
the state excuse me around the nation
there's something like 30 states in the
past 3 or 4 years that have moved to
this evidence-based instruction and I
think it's uh time for New Hampshire um
to move in that direction and I thank
you very
much thank you very much are there any
questions for representative
cordelli oh sorry just represent restive
Tanner thank you
um I don't know with an amendment
usually you don't get a fiscal note but
this is such a rework of the whole 1015
I was wondering if there's and it seems
like the local um Lea is going to uh
have to expend a lot of money as well
money and time so um I was wondering if
if there is a fiscal note or would there
be a fiscal Note coming and shouldn't it
include local
um uh if it is passed out of the house
it'll go to finance so um they will be
examining this um uh in depth I'm sure
and I as I mentioned I've already talked
to the chairman of Finance about
it usually we get a fiscal note here
though well yeah I'm not sure if um we
get a fiscal note with all uh
amendments um and um I can't remember
the bill last year if that had a fiscal
note or not attached to it um but this
is different in terms of of um I think
the grants uh section is different
because we're in the middle of a budget
season um I approached these as uh
competitive grants um instead of I think
what I had tried to lay out last year um
so it's a little bit different in that
regard because it's the middle of the
budget we have a follow follow yes so is
the Department of Education um will they
be hiring extra staff or a reading
specialist um they have someone already
on board um serving that function and
they won't be hiring additional staff I
I'm I'm not going to speak for the
Department uh in that regard but um
maybe Miss uh director white can uh
answer any questions in that thank you
well
vain any further question oh yes
representative luno thank you very much
Madam chair thank you very much
representative cordelli um throughout
the um the amendment and and um and and
actually in the the I I don't have it in
front of me but I think the um the the
Baseline Bill also refers to grade level
predictive measures and I was wondering
if you could talk with us a little bit
about how those are
determined um I I think maybe some
people behind me can speak to that um
more accurately than I
can okay thank
you representative
bbon thank you madam chair and uh thank
you for taking my question um just a
couple of things is this um this is
identical to the bill that we looked at
last fall um I don't think it's
identical the amendment the amendment
right well I have it's pretty
close so what's different
then um I'm not sure I've been working
on this for a long time so I'm not sure
exactly I haven't done it side by side
with the bill from last year I know the
reading um Grant section I believe is
different and some other sections I've
uh uh updated based on uh comments from
last year and even looking at the
original
1015 um follow yes followup um just well
actually it's kind of a different
question I'm sorry um you made the
comment that they are all interested in
doing this and I'm just curious
who well um for one um many of the
people um uh attending that um
professional development uh session that
I went to um the room was uh uh full uh
so I think that showed the interest um
uh from schools um uh as I recall
schools around the state were
represented there and I'm sorry I'm just
trying to determine that the what you
went to was something that was um put on
by the London da School District or was
it it was um it was a professional
development uh um session I think um put
on by the department if I am not
mistaken um with a presenter from um
Massachusetts all I'm trying to get is
is the scope representative bone follow
it yes please u i I'm just trying to
understand better the scope of the
attendance that was at that
event um I I did not have an attendance
list but I I talked to quite a few
people
there um I've been to various sessions
I've been to um there was a session um
uh I guess um this summer sometime um uh
with uh people who have been to the uh
letters training that the department is
paying for with over um 3,000 people
around the state Educators and parents
uh being trained in um in the letters
program which is training on uh this uh
evidence-based uh instructional methods
um and it was uh actually disappointing
uh for me to learn that I think it was
only maybe five teachers from our
Regional School District um had been
through this
training representative Hall you madam
chair uh representative would you agree
that because teachers attend these p
sessions they don't necessarily buy into
what's being presented they they go
because they're supposed to go or they
go because they need PD hours but it's
not that you don't assume that they are
buy I I I I'm not making that assumption
I just the people I talked to were quite
interested thank you representative
Tanner thank you this is kind of a
procedural question I don't um so your
original Bill uh or the original bill
underlying Bill to this one was laid on
the table um in in session right is that
what happened at
10:15 10:15 yeah no we haven't
um uh we haven't voted on that in the
Full House as I Rec it was your original
Bill the one that is almost the same was
tabled last year was tabled in the house
session yes so how was that able to be
brought
back because was
tabled
T oh yeah
itl right even though it hasn't been
taken off the table at the
house representative Luna thank you very
much Madam chair um on um on page two of
the amendment in section three and then
later in section four um section three
on line seven talks about an individual
reading plan and section four on line 35
talks about a reading Improvement plan
are those the same thing or can you sort
of explain what the what the difference
is here I I I believe they're basically
the
same thank
you any further
questions thank you very much
representative cordelli thank
you
um next we have representative Lori
ball good morning thank you for allowing
me to speak today um and also thank you
representative cordelli for all the hard
work that you put toward this amendment
in full disclosure I should say I
believe I am a sponsor on the original
uh bill that that representative
cordelli put
forward
um I don't know how to say this without
being uh wrong here but I am
disappointed that this um amendment was
put onto my bill um that I wrote the
reason being is that the bill that I
presented if you look at the original um
RSA it's this long it's one
paragraph and my intent when I read this
as I stated in my testimony last week
when I read that section it immediately
red flagged me that this was special
education wording it came from that
going back to that deliberation form I
shared last week that's where this came
from and my intent was to make this more
informational so people understand
exactly what the components are of
literacy and if you notice they include
math math and writing which I don't see
in this
amendment more
importantly the purpose and the re
reason for my writing um 1015 was to
Define literacy expectations in New
Hampshire to reflect the federal
guidelines and expectation used in
identifying children with a specific uh
learning
disability and to establish limited
timeline for providing RTI prior to
ruling out A literacy disability or
learning
disability I believe that my bill
presented an effective way to establish
just enough guidance to allow schools to
look more critically at their literacy
programs um that they may be considering
to
purchase while still allowing them to
have enough local control to choose
which program works best for their
district and their
students my concern with the bill now
with this amendment and all of these um
requirements being put
forward is that school districts have
already started purchasing programs I
know that in Salem they are already
piloting the Wilson Foundation program
in grades one and
two I know that because those are the
grades my grandchildren are
in I've also been informed by
constituents that Rochester Plymouth and
Kean have already moved in the direction
of getting rid of the old fest and panel
members
type method and moving into the phonics
based
instruction I was also told by a teacher
last year in nasua they literally threw
away the teachers were told to take all
the font panel materials and put them in
the dumpster so they have already moved
away and are moving toward the science
of reading or the phonics based
instruction my concern is that if we
start making more stipulations and the
programs and districts have already
started buying programs
RS that we could have a conflict and
that's why I think it's really important
to set our expectations right away and
not bog down the bill with all this
extra stuff we can always come back I
think the the idea of certifying
teachers and making sure teachers um the
students who are being certified as
teachers coming out of our colleges I
definitely agree they need more training
but I think that should be a standalone
Bill and not associated with what our
expectations are for the definition of
literacy um I was
also
um I'm sorry I again I I go back and I
say I I really commend representative
cordelli but even as a co-sponsor on the
bill I had mentioned to him I had
concerns um for one thing we already
passed a screening Bill last year so
that's already being
implemented the other thing is that when
we talk about screening in in his bill
there's no mention of ruling out vision
and hearing and dyslexia is a hearing
disability because children don't always
here they can't hear the
articulation um so that worries
me the other thing that I had brought
forward to him and I don't see that had
been changed is that the deficiency are
below age appropriate benchmarks but
when we identify children or we evaluate
them for special education as I showed
you the Wyatt last week the welshire
individual um the achievement tests that
we use academic um achievement test we
always use grade level
Norms we have to because age means
nothing I mentioned my two
granddaughters my granddaughter who's in
first grade is six she's the youngest in
her class while my granddaughter who's
in second grade is eight she's the
oldest in her class there's a two-year
difference in their in their ages but
they're only one year apart in school we
can't go by ages because that doesn't
tell us what skills we should expect
that they have been taught in their
grades so I believe that that needs to
say grade level
expectations or grade appropriate
benchmarks because then we would know
what they've actually been taught and
what we could expect them to
know um a few other
things that I was jotting down
is
um screening children when they come
into a district I think that's a
wonderful idea but why stop at third
grade I even go back to the testimony
last week saying that they should all
end at third grade that doesn't make
sense because phonics continues we're
still learning phonics in fifth grade it
what's included in phonics when we're
teaching um vocabulary we need to be
teaching root words Greek and Latin root
words if we don't teach them then how do
we teach teach children when to use a pH
for f sound versus an F Well we have to
teach them it's a Greek based word uses
a pH if we leave that out we're leaving
out we're making a gap where they don't
understand so now they're just going to
memorize
again phonics continues it's a lifelong
lesson we continue to dissect and
investigate and if we present it
correctly to our students it should be
fun it's a puzzle it's uncovering a
puzzle on how literacy works and
literacy doesn't just end it phonics it
includes vocabulary if we don't have
vocabulary we don't have comprehension
and that's why phonics going back to
that whole decoding is so important
because if children keep stumbling over
words they don't get fluency without
fluency they you know you fluency I'm
not really I should take that back
because fluency you should only read as
fast as it as you can comprehend
otherwise you're just reading words but
you need to integrate that into your um
background
knowledge but we can't have
comprehension if we're still trying to
decode so this this continues and it
doesn't surprise me to hear that in
representative cordell's uh District
that the reading proficiency levels
dropped in middle school that goes right
back to what I said in middle school is
when we find out when the reading
disabilities are there because we have
multi- slabic words and yet no way for
children to actually they don't have the
skills to decode those words so they're
reading level drops and that's why we're
identifying children in Middle
School um there were a few
other uh
items when I was going over the bill and
I don't really think I need to go into
every one of them I would really love to
work more with representative cordelli I
just don't think this portion is ready
for prime time yet I think it could end
up H um hindering the possibility that
we could pass what I put forward I am
more than willing to to amend if I can
or have somebody work with someone here
to amend mine to include the charter
schools that was talked about or even
take off section two if it's needed the
whole thing on the RTI and we do that as
a standalone but right now I think the
most important thing is to provide the
guidance to the school as to what
exactly we expect literacy education to
look like in the state of New Hampshire
and that includes encoding decoding
grammar mechanics writing mathematics
that's all part of literacy
thank you thank you do we have any
questions for representative ball
representative belter thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question uh the one thing I wanted to
get a little bit deeper in is you
mentioned that schools were already
starting to purchase um new reading
materials and whatnot do you have any
specific examples or or or programs that
you know of that are being purchased
that would not qualify under this um
this sort of rubric of evidence-based um
science reading well you have to keep in
mind that phonic is a standalone you
still have to have a comprehension a
reading program that includes
comprehension um and also we have a
writing component the other I keep
mentioning fontis and panel but Lucy
ckins is the writing program that has
also been debunked so that also needs to
be replaced um in many of the schools so
it goes beyond just the phonics I don't
know exactly I just know that in Salem I
know that they're using the the Wilson
Foundation programs for phonics in the
first and second grade I know they're
piloting it
um most good I haven't looked at every
single one of them but good reading
programs or phonics programs would
include these components but my concern
is that what's not included here is the
writing and the mathematics we're just
focused on Phonics and we haven't we're
kind of leaving out the other portion um
of literacy which includes math and
writing
any further
questions and seeing none thank you very
much um next we call on um Debra
house
good morning Madam chair temporary chair
good morning yes and uh my name is
Deborah H I'm president of the American
Federation of teachers New Hampshire and
I am here today to speak in opposition
of the non-gain amendment and uh
actually of HB 1015 as well
um I want to state that you know on
behalf of my members we are actually in
support of the goal of the bill and and
the Amendment but I do not think that
either is necessary at this point and uh
some of the timelines involved could get
in the way of delivering the help that
students need to become strong confident
readers um we have 3700 members cross
state most of them work in K12 education
many of them are directly involved in
teaching students to read every day and
that is my background I worked 18 years
uh teaching students to read in NASA um
and I'm also a parent of two
um adults now who took very different
Journeys on uh learning to read one
learned very easily and one struggled
with it mightily so I know this
personally as well as a professional um
my first concern with this is are either
of these bills necessary at this point
just last year this legislature approved
a uh law
RSA 259 that um change the universal
screening for dyslexia so every student
in kindergarten through third grade will
get screened with an evidence-based
reading screener that has many if not
all of the components that were outlined
in the non gerain amendment that we saw
today um administered twice a
year and uh you know you will see the
results from that and teachers need time
to look at those results and um that law
requires that schools take action upon
those results so that is what is in that
law that you just passed last year that
took effect September first this year uh
uh this 2023 sorry this school year uh
so when you see those results and you
see a student is below grade level on
one of those benchmarks of the component
skills of reading you need to do
something you need to decide whether
they need you know a little extra
practice in the classroom uh separate
intervention lessons um or whether it's
you know solo it's an immediate referral
to uh special education evaluation um
without giving that law a chance to work
it hasn't even had a full school year
yet you can't see if it's having any
results so piling either of these on top
of it would
be doing too much too
soon and um inviting
confusion and getting in the way of
helping students another concern is the
timelines in these bills both the uh HB
1015 has a timeline for special
education that that can interfere with
special education referrals and um the
non-main amendment has a very short
timeline for intervention
plans when you do the diagnostic
screening which was described in the um
in the nerain amendment you need time to
look at it because it does not tell you
once you see that student is below gr
grade level it doesn't tell you what you
then go and do it just tells you this
student isn't performing well enough in
this component skill say it's phonics it
doesn't tell you where to start you
don't want to waste that student's Time
by going back and teaching them that
this is the layer C this is the shape it
has this is the sound it makes if they
know the letter c already you need to
know which letter sounds you know which
letter shapes do they know which letter
s they know is it long vowels short
vowels where is it you start with that
student now imagine you have just
screened your whole class cuz you tend
to do the screeners all at the same time
because you don't want to lose a lot of
instructional time to do doing these
Benchmark screening you want to be
efficient so say of your class of 18 to
22 which is an average Elementary School
class it's not really one teacher to 12
students or 14 students um that's that's
a statistic that counts all the adults
with a teaching certificate in the grade
you know in the in the building not all
the adults actually in front of a class
um so say in your class of 18 to 22
students you've got six of them and now
you've got six school days to figure out
the reading intervention plan based on
what part of the Benchmark there below
grade level on that's not workable that
would be forcing teachers to come up
with
plans without having the chance to sit
and use their professional skills to
actually analyze what the student needs
and if it's not one of the really
obvious ones like phonics where you've
got a lot of background in working in it
you might need to consult with the
reading Specialist or cons consult with
a special education teacher to figure
out okay this student student scored low
here where do I
start and that's professional
collaboration that goes on every day in
schools when you've got a kid where
you're not quite sure what to do with
them and then you know for if so you do
need to group them together somehow so
that you're teaching lessons that mean
something to the student and help them
with what they need to work on but also
makes use of the time because there's
only so many hours in the day so we
don't want to be so strict in our
timelines and
so
um um um dictatorial in what we're
prescribing that it gets in the way of
actually helping students and the third
thing is we're um having having the
Department of
Education choose the screener and
possibly through these Innovation
grants choose the programs and and uh
curriculum I mean it's a carrot if
you're giving money but it also gives
them a lot of say in what you choose we
have districts already making choices
about what they want to use for reading
programs that should be a local control
issue but for these reasons we do have
concerns particularly about the non
gerain Amendment but also about you know
is HB 1015 needed at this time let's see
how last year's newly pass RSA 259 works
out and we we are all working hard to
help our students we need to trust the
professionals these are at this time
inexpedient to legislate thank you thank
you any questions representative
Terry uh so you the third person to
testify and I'm I'm trying to put all
the pieces together here and as I do so
and particularly with respect to your
testimony I I seem to be hearing that
you are saying what I'm hearing is that
you're saying is that we're already
beginning to address and to
fix uh problems in this
area and so we don't really need or
desire prescriptive
legislation to Define what it is that we
should be doing because we're already
doing a lot of what is being
proposed so if that's the case would you
either verify or correct
that misunderstanding if it's a
misunderstanding or or verify if I'm
correct and if it is correct would could
you explain what has driven in your view
what has driven a kind of Awakening if
you will that there needs to be a change
and why the changes that are being made
right now that you're describing are
somewhat in line with what we're
actually seeing in the bill and the
amendment
thanks uh you there is concern about
reading proficiency and reading
achievement um and there have been
numerous attempts to address performance
in that area some of them came together
sooner than
others I I think part of it is timing
this as you heard was also a bill last
year most of it um and didn't make it um
so you see some of that is still being
carried over um I I don't
think
doing similar
things one year after another is going
to result in better change it's just
going to result in more churn and that's
not going to help kids
learn oh follow
up so what was I correct when I stated
um that I thought that what I was
hearing from you is that we really don't
need either of these because the there's
a dynamic that is at work already within
the education Community to make the
kinds of changes that are being
prescribed in the bill Andor the
amendment in part or in there is a
dynamic out there that why is that
happening why is that happening and why
did it take so
long you know that Dynamic is out there
from
just you the
um you know internal process
of frequently
examining um Statewide assessment scores
and benchmark scores and looking to see
what can we do
differently it is a long process to
change within districts but um you it is
something that we examine on a district
level all the time and there is a
growing um Statewide pressure as well so
it
yep
representative belter thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question um you you referenced the uh
the bill we passed last year regarding
the dyslexia screener yeah and um makes
perfect sense that we would identify
it's good that we would identify such
students as needing help this bill seems
like so it has part of that part of
that's here but it also goes to the
other side of it which is once you've
identified a student that that has a
problem how do you address address that
student which is I think a significant
amount of what this is speaking to so do
you do you think that
um that what's happening right now in
school's absent us passing this bill
would already generally meet the
criteria of of addressing it with with
better techniques than have it been
previously used that has resulted in
problems uh the bill passed last year
does require that you act
upon the um The Benchmark testing so
that you don't just say oh well the
students Lo will grow out of it that is
not an accept acceptable action under
the bill that was passed last year you
have to um you take some action whether
it is additional support in the
classroom whether there is some kind of
specific intervention and I I would have
to look again I was reading it yesterday
um but I was also reading the non-
gerain amendment and um but specific I
believe it was not evidence-based
intervention and or it could be a
referral to special ed so there were
different Pathways you could take um but
it did require action as opposed to just
a wait and see um approach so it wasn't
well you know we could wait and see
whether they get better at the next
expect for that is not an acceptable
approach to helping students learn you
do need to take an affirmative action to
uh try and remedy the
situation you it's not as detailed as
you have six days to write a plan but
then again six days to write a plan is
not realistic if you want a thoughtful
plan as supposed togg just well I will
follow the letter of the law but you're
going to force me to have a canned plan
for every student that would not be
appropriate because it wouldn't really
help students learn it would just be
making people jump through
hoops any further questions
representative
luno thank you very much Madam chair
thank you very much Miss H um um I think
we heard testimony uh earlier when the
amendment was introduced that um that
and I um I I want to make sure I
characterize it right so please correct
me if WR you said uh
52% of students are State Statewide
Statewide so the my my question um sort
of has two parts to it um do some
districts exceed that Statewide average
and in those cases is what what what
what are you attributing to sorry excuse
me well obviously with an average some
districts would be exceeding that and
the districts that exceed it are the
ones that have better resources are able
to have lower class sizes fewer students
to teacher ratio um more learning
supports in place whether that is uh
highly trained par professionals who are
by the way are like assigned to one
classroom instead of just pulled here
and there to fill out the spaces in the
schedule so that no minute is left
unfilled in their day um so they can
truly collaborate and be part of a
learning team uh to support students um
and also have you know Specialists such
as a dedicated reading specialist in in
each Elementary building and the middle
schools um and um you know plenty of
onsite uh support from um school
counselors and perhaps a social worker
if if that is something that is needed
in the community um and and and many
other supports so that the students can
learn and thrive in the
school and a quick followup yes followup
so so so thanks and um and it it sounds
like what what what those districts are
doing is different than what this
amendment is suggesting but but is is
the science of reading is that a is that
a substitute for all the things you just
talked about well the science of reading
is
a wide
interdisciplinary study that looks at
how students learn to read it crosses
many disciplines of science it does look
at more than just phonics and
unfortunately it does end up in a
discussion of phonics most often but it
covers uh
many domains the skill component skills
of learning to read
and I'm sorry I lost the rest of the
question it is not a substitute for
having u a a well-functioning
well-funded school and
um you know in a community where you
have a lot of students who are coming
from another language background or
coming from uh a background
where you know you've got a lot of
families struggling at economically um
science of reading is only going to go
so far in
overcoming what students are bringing in
from outside the school so so a final
final followup on that thank thank you
so what um what I'm what I'm hearing you
say then is that is that while while
there there may be um evidence that
suggest the science of reading or that
that type of thing has has um some um
some
uh benefit in terms of instruction and
materials if it's with without the
proper um resources in place to
implement it it may not actually move
the needle uh in the direction we think
it's going to go is that what I'm
hearing it can move the needle but it
can't do the whole job
because a child is not a robot so you
know they're bringing their whole life
in with them every day
so what happens outside affects what H
outside of school affects what they're
doing inside of school great thank you
very much any further questions thank
you very much Miss house and next we
call on um Tom
newerk thank you madam chair um thanks
for this opportunity to speak to you my
name is Tom new Kirk I taught at the
University of New Hampshire for 35 years
I've served on the oyst River School
Board for 11 uh I have one more day
tomorrow is the end of my career there
um so I'm speaking for myself here I'm
not speaking for the board and I'm here
to speak in uh opposition to this uh
Amendment which really seems almost like
a new bill to me uh and um and it's the
objections I have are the same ones I
made last week because it seems to me
that it's important to figure out what
the impact of this bill is on local
districts and what pressure it places on
them this is a momentous bill as I see
it I think it would affect every school
every budget and it's important to
determine what the impact would be
financially and in terms of the demand
upon teachers of this bill um so one
thing that I did was I you know I I got
it on Thursday and first thing I did was
I circulated I I I gave it to one of the
reading Specialists who who's very
worked in a number of schools in New
Hampshire and I I asked her just to
annotate it and give me her reaction to
it and she thought even with the robust
intervention we have at oer River which
is a very well-resourced
School District that has made a real
effort on Intervention this tier 2 kind
of intervention she looked through it
and said we couldn't do this we would
need additional staff to do this even
given the efforts that we have because
of the requirement for an individual
reading plan for every student in tier
two essentially and the all the
reporting and um really the the the
paperwork that this of course we don't
use paper I guess that's a term well
whatever you you know what I mean okay
um just the the requirement for
reporting recording uh communicating she
would think we we need extra Personnel
even at Oyster River where we've put so
much into it which made me think what
would happen in a district that didn't
have our resources and that had some
more serious issues because we have
relatively we have students who need
this but relatively fewer than other
districts that have more you know come
from maybe lower soci drawn lower
socioeconomic groups um so I I just as a
mental and this was I did this pretty
much looking kind of calculating on the
envelope what would happen in Manchester
if this bill
went forward what would be the pressure
that was placed in
Manchester and so I did some
calculations and these are very rough
and you know I'm just kind of saying
this is the when when I I mentioned a
stress test when I came here before what
is the stress that this bill would put
on a district that had a large number of
students in this you know who would need
Improvement and they had to follow a
bill like this uh and in Manchester you
have I have some calculations here I'm
not going to just go through them but
essentially you have like almost 3,600
students in K through three um and if
you look at the test scores of you know
the state test scores grades 3 through 8
you you have almost 49% in the lowest
level okay that's 3 through eight and if
you if you assume that the 49% is the
figure for K through three or something
like that that and if you the 49% are
probably six 6 months behind grade level
if that's your
threshold you have something like um let
see I 1751 students who would fall into
that category
1751 and if you assume that some of
those are probably going to get some
special help anyways you know through
special education um if you even say 30%
which I think would be pretty generous
you come with 1225 students who would
fall into the category of needing an
independent reading plan according to
this
bill and I think it would be tremendous
if every one of those students could get
that but what would it take could could
you say that and I think you need to say
that in a in a city like Manchester with
their resources as they stand because
this bill if it's passed would be in
operation if you pass it in May it would
be you know operative in July they would
have to be have this all in place and
they would have to have at least if you
count if these figures are even close
almost
1,200 create 1,200 independent
individualized reading programs I mean
is that even realistic where would the
where would it come
from so it would seem to me I mean and
and you know these figures are just
approximate but I hope that you as a
committee look to see what the impact
would be of what you're asking
okay to create this is not just giving
support to to kids who need extra help
this is like creating a plan similar in
a lot of ways to what you do for a
special needs
student this is a very heavy
ask and so the reason I think that you
should at least be extremely cautious
about this bill and do your due
diligence is I think you need to see
what the impact would be on local school
districts what would they need to
provide that they you know that they
they might not be able to provide now
and I think in in low economic districts
it would be enormous it would be a huge
huge
ask and just
finally I think if you go into schools
now I think you'll see teachers under
amazing stress I think it's a very
difficult time to be a
teacher and I think one of the things
one of the things you wouldn't want to
do is to increase the demand upon them
without increasing the resources that
they need to fulfill that demand I think
that's a recipe for failure that's a
recipe for resentment that's a recipe
for feeling you know just increasing the
sense of stress the teachers feel now so
I'll I'll stop here because I know you
have a lot to do yeah yeah thank you
representative
Dy thank you madam chairman thank you
for taking my question um I'm thinking
back back to what we opened this hearing
with with the quote that said once you
learn to read you're free forever and I
wonder if you if we've taken into
account the fact that this will help and
there will be benefit down the road so
are you adding that into the equation
yes it might take resources now but then
maybe we don't need resources
later I think that initially you'll need
resources all the way through because
you know you're talking longterm so I
think initially you're not going to be
able to pull everything out of fourth
fifth sixth grade to to to do this so I
think that uh initially there'd be it
you wouldn't you wouldn't you'd still
have to increase your Your Capacity with
the younger kids and and there's no
there's no funds here there's no you
know like in our district there's no way
we could even increase because the
budgets are set for next year so so so
longterm yeah I can see what you're
point I think but that's quite a long
ways down the road because initially I
think this would just put tremendous
tremendous pressure on districts can you
see that I mean I I think that's a long
longterm answer but in terms of the
short term in terms of that you're going
to you're going to just
overload the uh kind of referrals the
testing the uh paperwork for the uh for
the schools
that's um just one second do we have
anybody else I we're out um Mr new
kerk's pink card was the last one that I
had is there anyone else waiting to
speak oh do you have a pink card I don't
yeah can you can you just fill out a
pink card and and submit it please thank
you all right more questions
representative Damon thank you thank you
for taking my question for being
here
so if if we accepted the premise that
excuse me that this set of protocols
should happen I don't necessarily accept
it but just that as a baseline to my
question and if we somehow believed that
there would be an abundance of resources
for these
grants um and disregarded they're
competitive so some districts would
apply needing money and not get it is
$75,000 per District anywhere near
adequate to do
this I think I think think it's a good
idea to have the
$75,000 I mean so i i u but I think the
answer is no because on the school when
I was on well I'm still on the school
board for more day that's right um uh we
always said like you can't use onetime
funds for long-term
projects you know and there's a tendency
to do that so you know you get you get
you know this happened with Esser funds
for some schools you but the Esser funds
were going to go away so so so so if you
get 75 $5,000 I think that would be
really useful for training I think that'
be really useful for um getting
materials for you know so I think it's
useful but I don't think I don't think
it solves this problem this is a per I
think a Personnel problem where you need
people to do this kind of work you need
more PA of professionals you need more
tutors uh and I think I think if you're
going to attack this problem you really
have to kind of put a lot of that money
or more you know in terms of personnel
earlier on that's that's what by even in
Oyster River we thought if you if we if
this was required we would have to hire
people we you know a $75,000 Grant not
that we get it anyways because I mean if
you have any kind of criteria we
shouldn't get it you know um uh um so so
even if even if you know you could get
it wouldn't solve that problem it's kind
of two different
things any further questions
representative belter thank you madam
chair thank you for being here uh I
heard a lot of of what you said but
there was there was one thing that I
wasn't totally clear on I wanted to
clarify a little bit I heard you say
that this would be especially difficult
for the school districts that are in a
lower socioeconomic area um however my
understanding is given given uh State
funding formula we use free and reduced
launches a metric or a standin for that
and as a result those areas that are by
income status Lower socioeconomic status
are funded to a higher degree by the
state so I'm trying to understand why it
would be more difficult for those areas
to fund it than anywhere else well I
think I think because still you have
districts like like Claremont that are
are struggling you know I mean even with
even I mean if you look at if you
compare I mean this compare Claremont to
Handover me 30 miles apart uh just the
the resources that Claremont has um are
so are so limited even even with the
additional State money okay um and to go
back to the earlier question one one of
the things that happens in a poor
district is you have all kinds of
instability one thing I don't think
money buys you Excellence necessarily
but it buys you stability so that you
don't have teachers coming and
going now oyer River we don't have
teachers come and go we hire them they
stay where do we get them we go to
places like summersworth and Rochester
and take the teacher and that teacher
comes so we create instability in in in
places like Claremont in
Rochester and we have stability in our
district so you have all these
advantages that come I think from money
and and the state the state funding
difference doesn't nearly make up for
that thank you any further questions
thank you very much Mr newer the next
card and I believe the final speaker is
Karen
llant good morning good morning thank
you thank you for letting me speak today
um I am my name is Camen La plant and I
am a reading specialist um in New
Hampshire I work at a middle school I've
had several years experience working in
both both Elementary um more years in
elementary than middle school but both
um my title is actually special ed
reading specialist because I work um
with a Special Education team at my
school and have over the past um several
years worked in that role so I have a
strong understanding of um both the
special ed process and um reading
development and
instruction um I wasn't completely
prepared to speak today so just took a
few notes might be a little all over the
place place but I also want to be able
to clarify and answer some questions
that came up um first of all I'd like to
say that I am um in support of the
amendment um I think what may be um not
emphasized enough is um you know there
obviously this is a comprehensive bill
um all the different components um being
the the screener for both reading and
spelling the reading interventions the
action plan um that needs to be
developed for each student which I will
say by the way yes an individual action
plan needs to be developed but that
doesn't mean that that student needs to
be seen oneon-one by an interventionist
so um many children um are seen in small
groups and um benefit from those
interventions um also um the fact that
it includes the products monitoring is
super important um the dyslexia bill is
uh certainly a step in the right
direction but because we only have the
screener in place for two times a year
it leaves um it leaves out an important
piece because that middle of the a
screener is very important so that
interventionists and teachers can adjust
their instruction uh based on that data
that comes in in the middle of the year
and unfortunately that didn't make it
into the bill um the workshops for
parents and families and Educators is um
important for obvious reasons and the
ongoing um professional development for
teachers is essential I know we have the
um letters program right now um that was
implemented by the state which is
wonderful and many many teachers have
taken advantage of it but some have not
and unfortunately um the last round is
starting this
fall um and I believe it's full so it is
something that needs to be addressed
that we will still have teachers out
there that don't have the proper
training um the reporting the
accountability piece is important as
well and I'm glad that that's included
in this um Amendment we didn't have
accountability with the previous
dyslexia um bill and I know that that's
uh the dyslexia screening is is part of
this amendment too and I think that's
important for the state to know um who
how many students have risk factors what
we're doing to address them and how many
students are making progress are we
moving in the right
direction um the most important one the
most important parts of this bill I
think is the part that speaks to um in K
to five I understand the screen or k to3
um phonic skills uh yes they can and in
some cases should be taught in all the
way up through grade five for those
students who have not um mastered those
skills um in the K to3 grades but the
fact that we are in this bill it states
that there will be evidence-based
instruction and K through five I think
is very important and the reason why is
because if we
are doing what we need to do at that
tier one level with our core instruction
we're not going to see many kids as many
children that need tier 2 instruction
and certainly not tier three instruction
sometimes we are creating reading
disabilities by not providing the proper
instruction in schools and um you know
specifically schools that are using
programs that include
uh the 3 queing system um you know those
programs are actually harming um many
children there are certain children that
can learn to read with almost any type
of instruction but it's it's not the
majority of students the majority of
students need the explicit instruction
and when you're telling them you know
you come across a word that you don't
don't know you guess at that word um
you're really just doing them a
disservice so I'm I'm very happy to see
that that is also stated in the bill
that will not um
continue so couple of comments on um
what has come up today um for questions
I know that um representative cordelli
was asked um who are the interested
parties that were in that Prof specific
professional development um I was there
it was a summer professional development
uh you know in my district it was
voluntary um I saw every uh group of
teachers who are there representing
their schools and districts um engaged
working on projects to get the ball
rolling in um being able to um Implement
a screener and provide the interventions
and all of that um I would not you know
as a teacher uh many years as far as
professional development goes yes
sometimes there is mandatory
professional development that schools
will Implement in their school and say
oh it's professional development day
we're bringing this into our school and
we want you to be there and learn about
it but there are many many many many
opportunities that teachers voluntarily
go to and um having a large network of
people that I work with and colleagues
and that um I would say you know to
answer that question you know who are
the people who are interested I would
say all teachers who care about kids um
we have way too many kids in this state
uh who are not reading proficiently and
we have an answer to it and I feel that
it's time for us to act um I would also
say that any teachers in the district
which I think there are 2500 or maybe
3,000 I could be wrong who went through
the letters training um I could I could
almost guarantee that they would
certainly be in favor of um the
amendment to to this bill and getting
these U the ball rolling with these um
this
legislation um just looking to see if
there are any other questions oh the
grade level someone asked about um the
grade level directive measures I think
um you had asked about that um those are
determined um you know based on the
research certain assessments have um
been put in place in schools certain
screeners like for example Dibbles or as
web those type of screeners and they
have certain criteria that need to be
met by each grade level so for a
kindergartener um it would be looking at
um you know f of awareness uh letter
sound knowledge letter sound
correspondences um can they blend sounds
together and then for first grade it's
going to ask for those skills and a
little bit more and um each grade level
has a different uh set of subtests that
um enable uh the school to gather the
data that they need for that particular
grade level does that make sense so so
that's where that comes in so not every
student would be tested I think it goes
a through H year not every grade level
would need each one of these
subtests to determine that they are at
grade
level um I think that is all I had does
anybody have any questions for me I
thought maybe I could does anybody have
any questions
sorry yes representative luno thank you
and thank you very much for for
addressing the the question that that I
had asked representative cordelli uh
earlier um the
um a question along that line though is
is where how are those benchmarks
established because my understanding is
the New Hampshire Department of
Education has been shifting proficient
proficiency benchmarks in the last
couple of years I'm not quite sure um uh
in response to what but but we did hear
from them that that they've been
shifting and uh and then the the second
part of my question if I may have a
second part to this would be how would
this be um be implemented what what
would it take to implement this in the
school that you work in um sure so as
far as the state um you know the you
know schools look at grade level
standards and try to meet those
standards and the
assessments can vary per School District
as far as what they give students to
help determine if they're um progressing
and meeting grade level benchmarks um as
far as you know what the state is
actually um asking schools to do I mean
there's the SAS right and um you know
that's the the assessment that's given
once a year in grades uh I believe it's
three and yeah the Statewide assessment
yep um so I know that that data is
looked at at the state level but there's
nothing in place right now that at the
state level that I believe in that
actually looks at the um screeners and
progress monitoring that's done in
schools that's what I see happening with
this bill being put into place um and as
far as how something like this would be
put into place I do uh hear you guys as
far as you know personnel and the
finance and and that whole end of it but
you know schools could certainly use
some guidance on um having an efficient
model um I know that the district is now
talking about mtss multi- systems of
support this bill would align nicely
with that and um basically that system
of support if you're not familiar with
it works just like this bill does
basically you know you're screening
students you're looking at the data
you're um providing interventions where
interventions are need needed um
continuing to monitor students and um
and that type of thing there are three
tiers so there'd be the tier 2
instruction the tier three instruction
tier three isn't necessarily specialized
instruction special ed but sometimes it
is um so I think that this bill aligns
nicely I think individual schools would
need to look at their personnel their
model their systems that's a lot of what
we um had learned at that Workshop over
the summer was you know it's a it's a
systems change um but in the schools
that I've worked in I think one of the
best things schools can do is look at
their personnel and say where are their
strengths what are their
training and how can we make this work
within our school by shifting some of
our um structures within the
school um I think schools that do have
you know reading Specialists and a
reading team are certainly going to be
able to to tackle this more so than
schools that don't but but I do believe
that the majority of schools now have
reading Specialists um a lot of schools
have now taken on the role that I have
as special reading specialist in
addition to their regular red reading
specialist so schools that have teams
like that could certainly um take this
on thank you any further
questions and oh yes representative
leus thank you thank you for coming and
speaking to us um so do you feel feel
that this bill is
doable I
do I do the the components that I can
speak to as you know my role um uh
certainly I do I've seen similar
structures happening in schools that may
just need to be um boosted up a little
bit tweaked here and there um but we do
there are screeners that are actually
free that you can use um and that I've
used in schools um that have helped us
monitor progress and put students into
intervention groups and I've seen great
gains when you have you know highly
qualified teachers and interventionists
working with
students thank you thank you any further
questions
and um a question of the chair uh I
don't know if there are any more cards
in there but I was I was wondering if we
might be able to hear from the um School
administrators Association because I do
have a question with respect to um
implementation and given the fact that a
lot of uh school districts pass their
budget for uh for next year uh uh
yesterday or
Saturday or Tom or tomorrow yeah the
recent passing of or or passing budgets
tomorrow is of significant concern for
many reasons not just this bill but yes
if if uh uh anybody would else would
like to speak to answer representative
Luna's question that would be
appreciated
great
Y and so I think yeah I I you know I
think my question to the chair was made
made the question pretty clear but but
implementation of a of a comprehensive
program like that given the fact that U
that budgets are um are are in the
approval process final approval process
right now and that implementation in
this bill would begin January of 2025
halfway through the school
year thank you Mr F Dr
fro thank you welcome good morning Madam
chair thank you for the opportunity to
speak to the committee this morning um
and happy to answer any questions I was
not prepared I actually came from a an
event um to get over here for because we
were supposed to have somebody in the
audience for the next bill so uh the
work session so anyway uh getting to to
the point and thank you for the
opportunity to address it um there are
school districts who have already
adopted their budgets for um next year
uh or will be having pretty important
votes tomorrow uh or over the next
weekend if if any live in the area may
have seen the issues that the Pembrook
School District are are faced with um
and the potential for a a huge budget
cut coming from the floor of their
school district meeting school districts
are not in a position right now to be
adding additional staff to Implement any
piece of legislation to be quite honest
um whether it's this or or any decisions
that are made moving forward the the
budgets for next year are adopted uh
within the next weeks for the most part
and this
significant uh shifting that is
suggested um we are we can't find people
to do some of these jobs right now uh
there are there are
um challenges in in a number of
districts and and have the opportunity
to meet around the state in different
regions and just
finding
um just finding folks let alone quality
folks uh that are that are trained and
able to do this and this is not a
condemnation to this to this bill and
and the the curriculum that's advocated
the letters training we have a staff
member who's attended the letters
training it's
fantastic the money however in all of
the grants that people talk about are
drying up school districts are hitting
um major decisions with Staffing and
supporting um the monies that are that
are being appropriated and so every time
a decision is made to spend local funds
um it's one
more crushing blow to local school
districts and um it's again it's not
about the methodology here uh teaching
kids uh the components of this bill is
is the right thing to do um but where do
we find the
it's not just finding a warm body we
can't find people to do the lunchroom uh
let alone uh to teach kids struggling
readers how to
read um directly to direct
follow so thank thank you very much Dr
Fu so um if we were able to to set aside
the fact that it's difficult to hire
people let's assume we could fi find
find
whoever school districts needed to um to
to to um implement
this do you believe there's a way of
estimating the Statewide local cost to
to provide um to implement this bill uh
K3 3 times a
year and I think there's some other I
think I saw maybe a fifth something
through fifth grade too somewhere but to
implement this bill a way to estimate
the Statewide cost to implement this
bill um Statewide serving you know
165,000 is
students thank you for the question
representative um there's always a way
uh it's a question of how um efficient
and how robust the data is and what the
current data should
right every school district has
different numbers of the of the number
of children that might need these
interventions right so everybody has
that
information um it's collecting it and
translating that to appropriate tier 2
level support and the potential for
special
education uh implications uh those those
are the wild cards if you will and
um perhaps over time that could be done
but but I don't see how that could be
done in the next 60 days or 90 days
or thank you thank you representative
McDonald thank you madam chair and thank
you for being here that brings me to my
question if we were to change the
effective date because the budgeting
process is largely underway in terms of
making this bill ready for the next
budget would that address a lot of your
concerns thank you representative for
the question uh it would certainly give
a runway for people to determine the the
financial impact as well as the state to
be honest to help support local school
districts because uh I you know the the
um and just let me site an example that
I'm familiar with all right when I was a
superintendent at
kirar because of our budget
situation as superintendent I had to be
prepared to present my budget for the
following year to the school board by
September
1st think about that September 1st and
then there were a series of Schoolboard
meetings and Municipal budget committee
meetings throughout all of the towns so
that they could have a deliberative
session the first Saturday in January
and then vote by ballot the second
Tuesday in March on on the ballot so
those are um kind of the timelines that
would be needed for legislation to take
effect in 2026 or 2025
whatever thank you
I actually have a question um what do
you think the academic outcome for
students would be if we do not enact
this legislation thank you for the
question Madam
chair I'm not arguing that the
legislation doesn't need to be
enacted um I believe that academic
outcomes can improve significantly
throughout our state
um given the right conditions the the
right learning conditions and that's
that seldom takes place the conditions
of for learning seldom take place in a
conversation uh in the legislature but
they take place all the time in
classrooms and offices in our state and
in our community so I do believe there's
hope to improve the performance
absolutely there there is uh and we have
um we have instruments and tools in the
toolkit that can be available but they
all
the resources of time in the school day
and uh demands on Staffing thank you we
do have another hearing coming up so is
this really pertinent to this or could
it wait for our executive
session you can I'm just wanted to make
sure that we know we have an agenda to
keep today too thank you thank you for
taking my question I represent about
half of Sullivan County which includes
Claremont Cen sonap and several other
small towns it's been referenced by
prior speakers Claremont as is
frequently an example of a inadequately
funded struggling school
system I think there are some amazing
Professionals in Claremont who work very
very hard at educating students but they
are the training ground and then the
stability question that was mentioned
earlier is very
real further Foundation from my question
cin and Arc Force school has a basically
four-person Staffing and we have been
absent one full-time staff member for
two consecutive
years so with those examples and there
are many many others throughout the
state as you know would you comment on
what we need to be doing to provide the
Staffing that would support this kind of
Bill you've said that you're not opposed
to uh the programming the screening and
programming and the bill but that we
simply don't have the people we need so
what would
help thank you for the question
representative I do believe that there
has to be flexibility and and decision
making available at the local level um
for um Staffing in in the ways that they
feel fit for the the four person croen
staff or the or of Manchester um
there has to be flexibility and and
opportunity to entertain talented
individuals
um locally and then the small rural
communities see this every day up up the
Upper Valley along the river up in the
North Country um Staffing is a is a
major problem so uh we have to have
flexibility to to help accommodate and
make accommodations for those staff I
don't maybe it was actually it was a
here the meeting that I was in to hours
ago that was talking about making
accommodations for
staff thank you thank you any further
questions and seeing none we will close
the hearing on the non gerain amendment
to House Bill
10:15 we'll take a five minute break
before we begin our next
session
our work session on the various
structures organizations of uh schools
in in the
state and just to make sure does
everybody on the committee have one of
these packets because we'll look at that
first before we look at yeah right
yeah okay what I what I put together is
just so so folks will have a a an
understanding of what some of these
agreements look like between Cooperative
school districts seeing that the bills
which we're dealing with today are not
all Cooperative school districts but
they do allude and speak to various
issues uh referencing Cooperative school
districts so I do have if there's
anybody out there that maybe wants to
follow along there are a couple extras
of these right here now um if if
somebody would like does anybody want to
have a copy there there's two exas right
there thank you is one here yeah I'm
going to give her this one and I'll take
the
original but I'll use this one to work
through Barrett are you willing to enter
in part of this discussion so you might
want to come up to the table if you
would please I know you're the resident
Guru on a lot of
this but uh in moving forward now um in
and and looking at that first sheet
which you have there which there is five
pages to it it lists the Cooperative
school districts which we have now
granted yes this is written July 1 2017
but those Cooperative schools districts
are pretty much here and and and you can
look at the message which that provides
you starting off with con of cook and
looking down through Dairy Dron Etc as
she move down um uh as you're looking at
the the quop names on the left hand side
you'll see a small check mark by some of
them those are ones where we have copies
of the agreements when they were
originally put together so that you can
follow that up and look at the agreement
with is uh governing that particular
District but in looking at this I also
underlined uh for you uh various
sections under each one of those which
show the
apportionment uh ratio between average
daily membership and equalized property
valuation there are some coops here that
fund totally based upon ADM only
that there are some that use the uh uh
some ratio perhaps for Capital costs
Capital Improvements there's others that
might be funding 90% ADM 10% based upon
equiz property
valuation and I don't know the exact
date in which Cooperative school
districts but we're basically going back
to the
1960s and when they came about and some
of these agreements were established and
haven't been really changed since that
time
but the individual town or district has
in terms of property valuation in terms
of population of of uh
students and this has become a bone of
contention between many of the districts
one of the districts which you'll see in
the in this report here after you'll see
all the agreements
um let's see where that one is located
um there there was a report an
investigation done pursuant to uh what
was going on with the district uh in
which we have up north where the town of
Carol is a part of that particular
Co-op and they've had a number of
appeals which have gone right to the
State Board saying you know we're paying
how much money per student it's over
$440,000 per student whereas you might
have some of the smaller other towns
within only paying $9,000 per student
and they're saying our population
changed our our our economic base in the
community is certainly not the same as
it was back then and it's simply not
affordable uh that that's something we
may want to look at when you look at the
town of Carol and Dalton and Jefferson
Lancaster Whitefield you can see that
the town of Carol um has very few
students in relation to you know perhaps
uh others so so that is something we
might want to look at I'm just going
through this very quickly also we have
had in the past a number of bills
dealing with how people on the quop
board are elected and do they have to be
coming from the specific town in which
they're representing or they voted at
large uh you have some co-ops where all
members are voted at large I live in one
there's others which uh are very very
different from that and so I have asked
Barrett to come forward and and explain
a little bit about some of these
agreements and some of the issues which
we've encountered um we certainly have
more information to explain some at the
last article in this whole packet you
can see there's a uh about a lawmaker
proposes the dissolving Co-op school
districts totally and reworking and
going forward he's sitting to my right
and that article is you know he has some
wonderful you know is in there which
he's explained to the conquered monitor
but um in dealing with even the I
concept of going with tuition programs
rather than the The Coop so look at that
as well but Barrett welcome and if you
have anything that you you know I think
we what the whole objective of this is
just kind of give a little uh prefix to
the whole issue of co-ops and why they
maybe were established and and and they
how they exist today and they are they
doing what they were initially sought to
be doing sure thank you very much
chairman lad good morning members of the
committee um I don't have anything
specific to really say more here just to
be a resource as the committee is
sorting through I think it's a half a
dozen or so Co-op bills um a little
history of of the of of the Cooperative
school districts though if you look
through the the document that chairman
lad handed out you'll see that many of
the Cooperative school districts were
formed within maybe a three or foure
period and sort of the early and mid
1960s um that was because the the
general Co-op law that we know it today
um as we know today RSA
195 um that version is is is the laws
you know it today has its Origins not
entirely but mostly in about
1963 there was a Statewide effort um
spearheaded in part by the legislature
and by the Department of Education at
the time to uh regionalized school
districts as a cost-saving mechanism
essentially um rather than having a say
a high school for each Town some of
these small talents with a th000 people
1200 people it didn't make sense for
them to have a to have their own their
own high school um from a from a fiscal
standpoint um but they also wanted those
communities to just um to not just
tuition districts Over the River and
Through the Woods as we like to say they
wanted that Community to have some stake
or bu in or skin in the game if you will
in um not just facilities but
administrative functions as well too and
the district as a whole um you know we
used to phras a Cooperative School
District or a Regional School District
um and the legislature again this is
sort of just going back from my own my
own research the purpose of of the
Cooperative School District Circa
1963 um was to to regionalize school
districts to build high schools um cuz
most of these Talent would obviously
have their own sort of K through 5 K
through 6 K through 8 school district um
and also share some of the costs with
the uh that would be attenuated from
from building a facility um curiously as
as some members of the committee may
know they built the building aid program
an RSA
9815 wherever that is in the in the
statute where if you're a Cooperative
School District you received more
building Aid based on the number of of
school districts that you had within
your Cooperative School District if you
had a three Town Co-op you got a certain
percent of your building Aid if you had
a four Town Co-op you got another 5% a f
Town Co-op another 5% on top of that um
and also sort of curiously the my
understanding is that um the
commissioner of education at the time
back in the the late 50s and early 60s
he went on a barn storming tour of the
state to sell the idea to the to the
local communities saying that this is a
good idea the state will help you build
your high school we'll regionalize we we
save money on on administrative costs on
facility costs um and also everybody
would have would have stake in the game
if you will in that in that political
subdivision The Cooperative School
District um we know that I mean fast
forward now 50 years ago or 50 years
since um we hear Rumblings from time to
time in a co-op here or a co-op there
about one town perhaps wanted to
withdraw from the co-op or one town is
um uh uh not um not in favor of the
apportionment method that the voters
have have have adopted previously so
we've had some bills in this committee a
number of bills I'd say the last six
years or so addressing Co-op some have
gone through some some have not um I
think um um chairman lad is so sick of
me saying this but I'm going to say it
again since I have the microphone that I
think we need the study commission sir
um again nhs's recommendation going back
a number of years would be a two-year
study commission to look at RSA 195 and
its entirety in its totality and I
chairman lad and I we've talked about
this and I know why that's not an option
right now but I'm going to I'm going to
keep saying until until until I get my
way I
guess um I kid um but anyway um so yeah
I mean there are there are there are
also Pockets you know nhs's position
generally with the number of Co-op bills
that we've had the last number of years
is that I think the law as it's written
is the law is not perfect there's room
for Change and updating in the in in
throughout RSA 195 I won't I won't
dispute that but I think Mo I think the
statutes as they are allow for um allow
for resolution of the issues that may be
popping up in one particular town or or
one particular Co-op um I also will say
too there are there are 32 Cooperative
school districts across the state you
know from time to time on any particular
Bill we'll get people representing one
Co-op two co-ops maybe maybe three
co-ops that come and testify they in
favor of the bill or whatnot but I think
by and large um the way the co-ops are
operating Statewide anyway um seems to
be the the people in those communities
again just anecdotally from what I'm
hearing and from seeing people that come
down come down to conquer to testify
that by and large things things work
well um with the the current structure
and within current articles of agreement
that that create these these Cooperative
school districts um but um so I don't
know I think I'm just kind of rambling
at at this point I mean I'm certainly
happy to answer any questions or be
whatever resource I can for the
committee but without a specific
question directed at me it just kind of
babbling along okay maybe one one thing
we can do sort of Might generate some
questions let's turn to one of these
articles of agreement let's turn to the
one dealing with gorm Olf and shelburn I
picked one from the North Country um so
that if you can hunt through your packet
here and come down to the agreement that
deals with
that uh there's not page numbers it's
it's
about maybe a quarter third the way the
way down in it's up in it says 95- five
other words 95% of the cost is based
upon ADM and the 5% based upon equiz
property
valuation um one of the things I like
about what they have in their artical
agreement and which is something that
representative cordelli and I have
talked about in the
past is that if you see going down where
it says members of the cooperate School
Board shall be elected by the
voters um and going through and and read
of the pre-existing districts they
represent and must be residents of those
pre-existing districts
the at large shall be elected by vote of
the three pre-existing districts voting
will be by the individual Town check
towns checklist all members elected
subsequent to the organizational meeting
shall be elected to threeyear terms at
the regular Town elections and it goes
on reapportionment of the coopa school
board may be proposed at any time in
accordance with New Hampshire statute
but in any case the ement as specified
above shall be subject to review for
possible amendments in 2010 and every 5
years
thereafter some districts do not have
this this phraseology at the bottom
there where they're required to look at
these agreements every five years but
then you have to look at okay who's
making that decision and where are all
the votes weighted they're waited to the
town of course that loves what they've
got going on maybe so um looking at this
they have 11 people on their board board
have to have an odd number anywhere up
to what is it 13 I believe 13 or 15
Manchester is 15 but because they're a
city they may be a little bit different
I believe Rochester is 13 but again a
city they're Charter or maybe different
I think the largest that I'm aware of
would be conil which I think is either
11 or 13
yeah so let let's just open this up to
some of the questions and issues that
people may have in their minds right now
in terms of The Cooperative school
districts apportionment or how they pay
you know if you look at that town of
going further north where I talk about
Carol and Dron and white Whitefield and
that there is one particular Community
that's getting hammered pretty hard and
yet they can't get out because they
don't votes get
out yes represent dry I think you may
have hit you know one of the nails on
the head and unfortunately we don't have
like fall mountains um
uh original agreement yeah um because I
think there is one town that has a
better equal equalized value was the
problem but the the contract was or the
original agreement was based on ADM how
do you change that if things have
changed since
1966 bar could you walk through for
example when how this occurs because
there has to be certain votes and then a
recommendation goes forward to the State
Board of Education you we have two
reports going up and the state board has
to make a decision on one or the other
um well that's only if if a town is
looking to withdraw from from TR to get
out in terms of changing the articles of
agreement that's simply a vote of the
body of the voter of the voters of that
Cooperative School District I understand
in some concerns that if the town has a
quote unquote good deal and they've got
the larger population there there
there's I understand there's not
necessarily an incentive for them to
change the the apportionment formula or
whatever it might be to the to the you
know stated or alleged detriment of one
of the other towns in the in the um in
the um in the Cooperative school
district one
of one of NHS Ba's frustrations is that
when when we're talking about the ort
and I'll get to the appeal in a second
representative when we get to and I'm
I'm not going to go on a school funding
rant or tangent here but but when people
are complaining about their property tax
that gets back to the to to the
mechanism with which we fund our schools
it's as simple as that one town is going
to pay more and you know that's the it
can't be it can't be even it's just not
going to be the mathematics just don't
work out if you've got a 100 kids you're
going to pay a higher rate than the town
that has 500 kids in that Co-op that's
just the economics of it so um you know
um you know in terms of appealing to the
to the to the Cooper appealing to
withdraw there is a process in statute I
believe it's
colon
uh I'm sorry it's it's in this it's in
RSA 195 I forget the specific um sub
chapter of that I'm looking at it now
was it 18 maybe
19 um where a town can can can put on
the warrant article you can do this both
at the Cooperative School District or if
you're the pre-existing town you can put
it on your Town warrant not necessarily
the school district warrant to initiate
a a a a study of your current
Cooperative school district and the town
that initiates that can look at
withdrawing from a Cooperative School
District they can look at changing the
articles of agreement um if they are
looking to withdraw um there's a process
in in statute where they have to go
through a uh um you have to go through I
believe it's an 180 day study committee
locally that and statute tells you who
has to be on the committee um they look
at the numbers they look at the
apportionment and then that vote is is
sent out um we changed that law was that
just just last year we changed the law
for the three- fifths voting and and and
and and calculating the vote on withdraw
if the withdraw goes through it has to
go to the State Board of Education to
make sure that the withdraw plan has all
the elements that the the statute
requires that are checked off I don't
think the state board has any particular
authority to weigh in whether or not
they think it's the withdrawal is a good
idea or a bad idea it's it's more does
the plan list all the the things that
the that the statute says that plan has
to um include and then it goes back to
the to the voters again um to um if if
the State Board allow allows the
withdraw if it goes back to the to the
voters again to to formalize um to
formalize the vote uh upon withdrawing
so that town then withdraws from that
Cooperative School District they are no
longer a no longer a community that
Cooperative School District the last sa
I'm sorry the last Cooperative School
District that we I think we've had a
couple here and there break apart a town
here a town there over the last maybe 15
years um I think the most significant
one to my recollection would be um the
madok Regional School District um they
had two or three towns withdraw I want
to say in the mid to late 2000s sui for
example withdrew Sullivan withdrew I
believe hin Dale used to be part of
manano if I'm if I'm not mistaken as
well too so um that was um probably like
2008 2009 um there have not been too
many withdrawal Co-op withdrawals that I
can think of off the top of my head in
the last maybe 15 years or
so yes thank you and just so just to
expand on that um I'm not sure that
withdrawal was the is the answer in that
case because they tried to withdrawal
and it it didn't pass right
so you're saying that a different it
might just be the terms of the you know
the co Cooperative district is the
answer but the terms are not um what
they want and so you're saying the
better they can do that internally they
thank you for the question
representative yes so I I should have
clarified to for starting from the
beginning Cooperative school districts
and and somewhere in the packet are
governed by what are called articles of
agreement it's essentially a contract
between the communities that have that
have chosen to form this Cooperative
school district and create this
Cooperative School District those those
articles of agreement can be altered or
amended it has to be approved by the
voters obviously but you don't have to
go to the State Board of Education you
don't go have to go to the to the
Department of Education I think you have
an obligation to submit your your your
your new um articles of agreement to the
department but they're not involved in
the process at all and um but so yeah
you can change you can change your
apportionment formulas you can change
you know is it population is a property
values whatever that might be that can
be done sort of internally by a study
group of the board if you will or the
communities and they're put out to the
voters to change the articles of
agreement representa
leus if you have a small school district
or a number of small school districts
and a large school district is it then
possible that
the small District which either wants to
change the Articles of Confederation or
wants to withdraw can be outvoted by the
larger school district and thus actually
not be able to do anything yeah thank
you for the question I we've seen that
and we've heard testimony to that effect
the last few years in this in this room
haven't we um that's one of the yeah
that was one of the frustrations with
some some individuals that came and
spoke that excuse me they're in the
smallest town Within the co-op and so
they know Co-op whyde they'll never have
the votes to change everything um I know
we changed the the co-op with draw I
forget the exact numbers the three-
fifths and super majorities and things
of that nature that that that that this
committee and nhba nhsb worked on I
guess my response to that would be
um to some degree there needs to be a
change of mindset I think among whether
you're in the small town or the large
Town The Cooperative school districts
were
created again sort of bringing people
together and and and the one aspect of
creating the the co-ops back in the in
the in the 60s that I didn't mention is
that property Rich talents were
purposely joined with property poor
towns with sort of a recognition that
we're all in this together right and
that you know even though I live in town
X I still have a a vested interest in
making sure the kids in town wide get a
proper education as well too um sort of
a Statewide recognition um but um um
where was it so so you know and I
understand that you know if you're if
you're elected from town a you have uh
your first duty is obviously to the
constituents in town a that elected you
but you also have further obligations as
a Schoolboard member to the district as
a whole to all the kids um and not just
all the kids but pres we all the
taxpayers and as well to cooperative you
know we're it's a it's a group concept
it's a group mindset so you know maybe
maybe we need to be able to compromise a
little bit more and say you my taxes may
go up a nickel but next door their taxes
are going to go down a dime and it's
still good for everybody I mean I'm not
I'm not the one that has to live that
and I'm not the one that has to
negotiate that but the the concept or
the notion or the mindset that it it
it's the collectively it's what best for
the Cooperative School District not
necessarily what's best for this town or
what's best for this town but I mean
those are decisions made by locally
elected officials in their communities
I'm not you know that that's not for me
to to say but rather sort of looking at
the broader concept of of why we had
co-ops to begin with thank you thank you
we had go ahead r s
Bel thank you Mr here I just wanted to
clarify for my own sort of benefit how
this how this kind of works um it seems
to me that based on the fact that things
change I mean Industries and towns can
change residencies can change over you
know years and
decades it seems that because there is
no mechanism for a single town to
reliably initiate a withdrawal by itself
from an
agreement that it's at least conceivable
that within a district as things do
change and one town may become more
property rich or poor the more town
within that District or the the more
original districts within that
Cooperative District that um are
benefiting from that change compared to
one town that may be not benefiting from
that change it actually seems the more
tilted it becomes the more difficult it
is for one town to possibly get out is
is that accurate yeah thank for the
question representative I that that's
certainly a a fair and reasonable way to
look at it AB absolutely abolutely yeah
if you have two districts A and B in a
co-op just two and a wants to get
out okay it's going to be very difficult
for them to get out seeing that then
this District here that remains as a
single District it's going to have to
buy all the capital investment that town
a has and it's a huge cost yeah and
thank you very much if I if I may
expound on that chairman lad let's be
clear to the withdrawals
and and when the study commission is
looking at some of these things it's not
always just about I mean the the
ultimate decision the ultimate factor is
not always just about sort of a portion
formula um for example if there's a an
outstanding Bond on a building the town
that that that's looking to withdraw
they still owe even if they withdraw
because that agreement was they bonded
that with that town in there and those
other three other communities were
counting on the revenue from that fourth
community so it it it and and then and
then you've got to you've got to pay to
get out where where are the facilities
who's going to buy the facility you know
if you have the if you have the let's
say the high school in your town or your
community as opposed to you know little
Elementary School K through 4 that's
going to impact you know what you buy
out what other people have to pay in
there are collective bargaining
agreement issues that that come into
come into play with this as well too
because if you have staff that are part
of the Cooperative school district
teachers union and then a town withdraws
that carries half their staff with them
suddenly you're going to have to create
a new bargaining unit over here as well
too you're going to have to start from
scratch with a with a with with a new
with a new collective bargaining
agreement as well too so it's not always
just about taxes it's about buildings
and facilities and staff and and taxes
are one part of it I'm not going to
overlook that fact um but there are a
myriad of of factors that that the study
commission study committee excuse me has
to look at locally when they're
considering these
factors further yes represent cordelli
then represent tannah thank you
um um I I think uh chairman lad you
touched on um Carol and the White
Mountain Regional School District and as
in the middle of our packet there is the
um letter from the State Board of
Education to the White Mountain Regional
School District um and it touches on the
fact that
um under
19529 um if the majority voters uh
reject a plan the withdrawing districts
has the right to appeal to the State
Board of
Education but the final outcome from the
state board's investigation of the vote
in uh the White Mountain Regional School
District is um that uh state board of
education has no authority to reverse
the outcome of the election right so uh
basically they're they're stuck they I
think this was the third or fourth
attempt by Carol to withdraw from that
school district um so I I think that you
know that goes to the whole uh voting um
and um make up uh a problem um but I
think Switching gears to a different
branch um if I might um it reflects also
um in the membership and we had a bill
this year and it's on our list here
1383 that um got into a little bit of
the membership of the board um of the
Cooperative district and that goes back
to what chairman lad mentioned also um
we had a bill in
202 yeah um SB 353 and I think a copy is
attached or we have copies where we
tried to address that because um uh I
think Mr Christina mentioned it's it's a
collective um but in many districts that
Collective votes for the member of a
little
town um I know that's the case in our
district where uh poor little Effingham
um wants to elect someone from their
Town um which is fine but the entire
Cooperative right votes on who that
member from Effingham should be so very
often um it's the um maybe the um
locality the largest locality where the
uh sa is headquartered everything else
they want their person who they like in
Effingham to be on the board so that's
who gets voted in not the necessarily
the person that that um a lot of people
in Effingham want or the majority of
that's the last election the majority of
people in Effingham wanted person X but
person B got voted in because wolfb
wanted them right so I think that's a
problem and that's something we
certainly can address that's something
we do need to address and and and going
on just to while you're looking at that
that the the the co-op that we're
talking about Whitefield Carol and
dressed in that if you go to page five
and six you can see why Carol's so upset
they're paying
$46,000 per
pup Dalton Jefferson Lancaster and white
pay 99,100 14,700 5,700 8
9,700 per
pupil if you Liv in Carol would you have
you know a
concern in that in that investigation
findings the on on uh that represent
cordelli was mentioning that report if
you look at Pages five and six of that
of that report at the bottom of page
five you'll see yet Carol pays a per
puple tuition rate of 46
Grand it's about half it's about halfway
through the
packet and on the top of uh page six you
can see one two3 the other four
districts what they
pay 9,000 14,000
5,000 9,000 per
pupil this is why Carol has gone to the
state board so many times on this and
remember you got you have to have when
you're trying to get out you have to
write a report uh which is going to deal
with
sustainability and and and and how
you're going to function and then move
on then two reports go to the state
board and the State Board looks at and
sees if you checked all those budget
boxes it comes back and of course it's
like a gorm where you have six board
members coming from
gorum one from
shelburn and one from Randolph and three
at
large and you can see how that's all
going to stack up goram's going to have
the six that's out of the board of 11
they already have a majority but then
they control the at large as well so Mr
chair yes so so thanks and I and I do
recall I found the the the page you
referenced and I do recall having this
conversation I think on a couple of
several bills that we've looked at over
the over the last um few terms um but
but you know even even looking at the
recommendation on the bottom of page of
of that report page five you know it
talks about how back in 1963 something
was a certain way and and over um over
you know five decades things have uh
things have changed and now now the
ratios are out of whack is that that's
correct right so so I guess sort of
stepping back from yeah there's there's
all these sort of acute problems that
have developed over the last 50 60 years
with a lot of these co-ops what what's
the what's the
general what what's what's the
committee's feeling in in terms of how
we go about uh addressing this thing
because at one point these were um you
know contracts between you know an
agreement among towns that they all like
the terms of the agreement uh and and U
you know as I think a lot of people
probably know you know uh agreements
along with a lot of other things don't
necessarily age really really well and
uh and that's why a lot of agreements
have breakup terms and and stuff like
that in them and and unfortunately a lot
of these didn't have have have terms
that that would
deconstruct um but um you know what I I
I've I've I've heard some things in the
past like the general court doesn't
interfere with private contracts and
things like that and I don't know to
what extent these are considered to be
private contracts but clearly and I
agree with you Mr chair that something
needs to be needs to be done the the the
only thing I can sort of relate to um
you know in a in a similar you know
similar situation affected a lot of
people is um is some work that the
legislature did several years back um
with respect to uh uh uh agreements in
um oh what do they call it um
Condominiums and and um and you know
call things cuz a lot of those did not
have standard I uh terms and conditions
or um and and and it was I remember it
was really frustrating and I was on
Commerce at the time because it's like
now the state is looking at interfering
with with with private contracts but
these things don't age well so the
question is what I I there's one thing
about cleaning these little acute things
up piece by piece or setting something
that ends up being a a i I think that I
I hear where you're driving and I think
that's the frustration that we had and
that was what I think generated
represented cordell's Bill break them
all up and let's start over from scratch
you know it it's it's you know you look
at Whitefield and you look at their
ratio uh of you we were just talking
about it where it's 60% based upon ADM
and 40% on um uh awise valuation what
happens if property values are changing
but we're still at that 40% or the
population's changing but we're still at
that other ratio but then if we do
increase that that's it's it's what are
we going to do again in another 20 years
come around again you're going to have
acute problems again yeah
thanks so represent Damon represent
Tanner you next excuse me then represent
Damon yeah thanks um
so I guess I was uh started teaching in
' 69 so karge had just formed as a
Cooperative so I remember a lot of the
haggling and waggling and everything
that went on and the fact that they did
put property Rich towns with property
not rich towns um
and I I think the kir Serge has gone
back several times and and redone their
articles of agreement um it seems from
sitting on this committee because this
comes up all the time that the that you
can pinpoint maybe five to 10
cooperatives in the state that are
knocking at the door all the time have
the same complaint all the time um with
one small town or the fact that you know
the Cooperative isn't working rather
than throwing the baby out with the bath
water uh because there is a an economy
of scale um and we've also talked about
how topheavy uh schools are with
Administration and this kind of co uh
excuse me puts the administration
together why don't we identify excuse me
those that are having problems and speak
to
those I think I got the gist there thank
you thank you I mean I don't know if
there was so much a question in there if
that was directed to me representative
but I mean that's sort of one way to to
look at it as well too
um the other thing to um I don't know if
this is a problem but just sort of for
the historical background for members of
the committee um we see that um a lot of
the districts of co-ops were formed in
1963 1964 1965 it's my understanding
this is not don't take this as gospel
because I don't know for for certain but
it's my understanding is that the
Department of Education developed sort
of a template articles of agreement and
then shipped it out to everybody and
then so there so you know there was a
tweak here and a tweak there but if you
were to look at it they all those that
were adopted from say 63 to about 66 or
68 they're all probably about 80%
similar and then there were some local
changes here or there as well too so
sort of to represent of Luna's Point um
there's no Escape Clause there's no it's
not like we signed a prenup when we when
we enter this marriage right and say
upon dissolution of the Cooperative
School District we're going to have to
you know get it here or there now we're
trying to figure that out now 60 years
into these contracts having been having
having having been in place I mean I do
like the idea representative chairman
lad you pointed to the the goral Goram
shelburn Randol language that you know
they have they have built in that will
review these every every five years you
know statutory language I think I'd
probably go every 10 years just cuz if
you do it every five years you're going
to be doing it all the time then but I
think that's I don't think nhba would
have any particular objection to that
and at the very least it's probably a
best practice anyway that you're looking
at your your your property tax rates
your apportionment rates your your PO
your student population rates your town
population rates cuz those those could
be very different um and certainly
different than they are or were when
these articles of agreement were were
initiated 60 years ago or
whatnot represent Damon then represent
Balon and then another hand I saw down
here thank you so I think um my one of
my two questions may have just been
answered but just to
confirm
so has there not previously been an
effort to put into statute a requirement
to revise or at least review and
possibly revise the Articles of
agreement every X number of years has
that ever been attempted to put in
statute we we've talk had a lot of talk
about this but I don't think we've ever
had I don't think there's ever and
there's been concurrence on this idea
right but we've never gone forward with
something that we may start considering
and then I have a imped why not right I
think there were other issues which were
really surfacing we had you know uh uh
issues how people are getting elected to
the board um advisory budgets and all
that those kind of surface to the top
and this other one which snuck
underneath the radar the whole time we
never got to which I I think that's
something that we could handle and and
probably go forward with something uh
there were several other people first I
one more yes thank you so the other
question is also has there ever been an
effort to put into statute with actual
bill
proposed a cap excuse me a cap on the
per student responsibility and I don't
mean an actual dollar cap but in
proportion so when you look at like the
uh White Mountains District in the huge
disproportion between Carol and what the
other towns pay has there ever been
effort to put in statute for all co-ops
we we do have the first bill on a doet
is $195 that's dealing with uh different
methods for
apportionment but take a look at linol
sir that that's for SE cost that's not
that was okay but if you look at like
Lincoln Woodstock which is a Cooperative
they don't a portion based upon ADM or
they do it just a percentage by Town
yeah Lincoln has 65% Woodstock
35% that's it and it wouldn't it
wouldn't surprise me either if that's
reflective of the the student population
as well too I don't know but I'm just
saying it may you maybe 65% of the
population is from that town 35% is from
the other town I I don't I didn't read
their their agreement on that but
there's there's some real issues up in
that particular Community with the value
of the ski areas and all that and equ
property valuation is you know high and
and that's and and some of the incomes
of those working at these Resorts is low
and that there be it the
issue there were represent mil there was
somebody else represent Bon represent
Bon you had your hand up before
everybody up front
here uh thank you Mr chair it's actually
a kind of a wide question um when the
governor spoke at his State of the State
address and one of the things that um we
hear from the governor and the current
um education commissioner is that with
declining School enrollments that we
need to be looking more at
consolidations and all we keep hearing
is about how people don't want to
consolidate so it seems like a just a
big philosophical issue in terms of
where we're going here um and I don't I
don't I don't know what kind of a
question that is but well it's exactly
what Vermont went through the middle
this last weekend when they went forward
with their they've already had their
Town meetings school board meetings
onethird of all the towns in Vermont
voted down the school budget correct and
they're in the they're in the they're in
the mess because of they did this
so-called consolidation yeah they they
Consolidated they're still finagling it
but was about maybe five years ago they
went from I had the numbers somewhere
and I mean we know main tried
consolidation 15 16 years ago that that
didn't that didn't go well but
concurrently we had you know co-ops that
were seeking to break up and the the
process for withdrawing from your school
Min review Into Your SAU is as easy as
can be I mean we have we have 20 more s
more than that I started an nhba in 2005
I believe we had 84 saus Littleton was
the the most recent withdraw we're up to
what 107 now if I'm not mistaken so more
than one a year and that's just the SAU
I get the the issues are different but
you know the the we're seeing the
breaking apart in New Hampshire where
our neighbors were looking at
consolidation yeah that's well was
represent yeah represent LE then
represent
mybody so I guess my question is even if
we say we're going to look at these
every five years or every 10 years or
whatever we say we still have the issue
of a big town controlling controlling it
and how do we deal with that I mean
thank you for the question I mean I I
know you're sort of putting that out
there almost philosophically and not a
direct answer I mean you know one of the
you know when we talked about some of
the voting bills and how the people are
going to be elected from from whatnot um
and I I forget the the representative's
name I believe she was from Hillsboro
Dearing and she talked about how Dearing
has 2,000 people Hillsboro has 4,000
people but yet the people over the 4,000
people in Hillsboro still get to vote
for the the Dearing rep as well too and
that's what you explained well too
representative cordelli we can make a
system where only the Dearing residents
vote for the Dearing rep and only the
Hillsboro people vote you know reps vote
for the the but what you're still going
to run into is because of the one man
one vote Provisions the bigger town is
going to have more Representatives than
the small town so you know that that's
going to be so whatever vote is before
the the people or the election or the
warrant article or the
that's kind of you know that's the
nature of you know the nature of of of
of what it
is I think uh the last time we looked at
this systemically was the grure look and
that was what
2016 something like that 16 17 yeah
something like that that's in the packet
that report it's in there and the
concern I guess I have
as we look at this as we look at the
multiple issues that have emerged just
this morning is you know we can try to
peac meal this thing
together or we can try to have a more
Global look at this because I do think
that there the um conditions have
changed we we've mentioned several
student count uh a poron etc I know
maybe maybe that would not trying to
kick the can down the road here but I
guess I'd rather kick kick it down the
road and get something substantive than
trying to continue to just Pac meal this
thing together with some kind of a a
commission or a group that could look at
this and say okay let's look at the
funding let's look at the governance
section of it let's look at the student
population section and then the the
charge to that group would be to come
back with some legislative
recommendations so that it would be a
full package looking at this rather than
just contining to do a little bit here a
little bit there not really addressing
the totality of it I mean I this clearly
is an issue that that needs to be
addressed and I just trying to figure
out figure out a way to look at this
from a systemic standpoint rather than
just from a peac meal standpoint so that
would be the concern that I would
have representative
cordelli uh thank you in terms of uh a
length of time for reviewing the
articles of agreement um I'll just read
the the last uh sentence from um the
bill SB 353 in terms of reapportionment
um says reapportionment of members of
The Cooperative School Board should be
reviewed revised and updated no less
frequently than every 10 years and
reapportioned if necessary based upon
the latest Federal Des Centennial census
and pursuant to several
rsas um so that was that but um in terms
of addressing the maybe the the
districts that aren't happy um I'd be um
actually I was thinking of this as an
amendment um back in uh 2022 when I
introduced it my but my dissolution and
repeal um of Cooperative school
districts I'd be very glad to upfront
put in a common phrase if you like your
Co-op you can keep it we've heard that
phrase applied to many things before so
I'd be glad to reintroduce it with that
Amendment
and uh
2022 it was uh SB
353 and it was an amendment amendment
number I think it's in your packet there
there is a rough draft of that amendment
in the packet I i' I've got copies of
the actual Amendment and this this
helped generate what uh representative
cordellia just mentioned and you'll see
the last sentence on the third page
there it does talk about uh the 10-year
reapportionment time frame and and Etc
and using that
census okay were there other questions
on this right now this is just sort of
just opening up these questions and
issues that are associated with co-ops
and it's just Laden with
questions represent oh% represent
leus
thank you all of this just kind of I
started writing down a a maybe an idea
if um we take a vote in each Co-op town
by town and if all the towns in
particular Co-op are happy with it we're
done um if not they have a certain
amount of
time to come up to change whatever um to
try to come up with something that when
we take that vote
again if they all agree now cool they're
done if they don't agree it gets
dissolved and we start
over just an idea that I was just
thinking
of represented
Amon thank you I'm going back a good bit
in this discussion because I just want
to make the observation that if one were
to replace co-ops or some
co-ops with
dissolve them in with tuition in the
students towns that tuition students
have no
representation on the school school
boards of those school districts they
have
basically um you're paying your tuition
but you do not have any voting
opportunity to influence what is
happening for your students even if all
your students go to the same
community
I'm trying to recall do we have any
co-ops in
co-ops I mean yeah I mean you have one
you have one up in is that
Romney no and those up all the way up to
Campton Romney oh is that 48 and down
south is that the part of the Plymouth
Co-op py Baker I think we have co-ops
within coops well is I mean you have
Woodsville is a co-op isn't it isn't
that's no no hail's uh was because he
had there were the two there were the
two districts within the town that's
right that's what Dairy is essentially
Dairy is a whole other weird animal that
I don't even know how that I think that
took an Act of the legislature to get
created if I'm not mistaken but when we
were dealing with Bridgewater last year
yeah yeah there is one up there that has
oh no um they're tied to the southern
district there it's an there's there's a
couple co-ops in
sa35 which is like Bethlehem
profile um Lafayette Regional there's I
that I I without pulling up the
Department of Education list there is a
co-op within a co-op yeah I think it's
may be the one in sa35 that you're
thinking of Mr chair
okay okay um further discussion maybe
yes there's a also a co-op Dresden which
is includes the town in yeah and that's
what messed up cuz they have norch
Vermont and norch takes their kids to
Hanover High School right that created a
nightmare in terms of when they were
mandated to be K through 12 in Vermont
right and nor is saying oh no no we're K
through 12 in this relationship across
the river right with intergovernmental
District yeah and it just tore apart
everything they're trying to do in that
state um okay I think what we ought to
do is look at Several of these bills
here and weighed through a couple of
them first the
1195 is a bill which relative allowing
school districts to approve different
apportionment methods for school
administrative units
saus which is a different
animal any discussion on that one right
now
yes repent
B um thank you Mr chair it's uh my
district my
Sao uh so I know a little bit about it
what's going on there help out um
they're not happy with the abortion
methods being used and um I had inquired
whether they had tried to just talk
within the seu itself to try to get it
resolved and there seems to be some
question whether or not legally they can
um as far as I know it has not been
brought up at the SAU level in terms of
a
discussion does is there anybody that
needs some help in trying to Define what
an SAU is
organizationally represent Bon you had
your not in this one that question but
thank you you Mr chair um So based on
everything we were just talking about
for a while and understanding let me see
if this makes sense to anybody else
based on this bill so the potential
problem I'm seeing I don't know how this
would actually play out in the real
world but hypothetically anyway it seems
that this is a situation where we've
just heard that a number of you know
districts original districts within a
Cooperative District could be in a
position where the one town could get
more more sort of tilted over time
against it and it can't really do much
about it because the articles of
agreement do not allow it to withdraw
unilaterally nor does New Hampshire law
as of right now it seems to me that this
would actually have the potential to
make it considerably worse for them
because it would allow that same sort of
majority within the school board to vote
to change the apportionment method in
such a way that it could actually become
worse for that town that's already
already being
disadvantaged um outside of the current
articles of agreement it's it's like
we're intervening in a way that could
really make this worse unless I'm unless
I'm missing
something my the district which I'm in
is
sau23 it has within it the haal co-op
has Benton has bath has
Pont uh
Warren and sau23 Co-op is saying we want
out because we feel we can educate our
kids cheaper but to get out then you
have the issue of who where are all the
buildings located for those others
they're all in
havil and and so they're locked in they
can't do that because they're going to
have to buy it all you know the cost of
all those other towns Benton bath which
is sizable and and uh Warren and and
permont uh so this is a real nightmare
how we've organized this entire State
whether it's saus or
co-ops yes represent tner I think one of
the you know I agree we need a study
committee for this or a commission of
some type but I think we also can look
at some of the ones that have happened
and and what's been the major problem
like lster oan which was where Jim
Grenier was involved with and like you
said it was a nightmare when they when
they split up um and H how you know kind
of
a pathology report on it I guess uh I
would I would say to look at that as
well as looking at the ones the the
commonalities between all the districts
that are having Pro all the co-ops that
are having problems it seems like you
know it's it's one small town that's
having an issue in most of of these and
when we talked about Hein when Hein was
here and we had all that discussion the
the people at the
SAU felt as though they weren't informed
and they didn't have an opportunity and
and I think representative Bon you just
said that the district hadn't really
talked about it and so you know some of
it is this this feeling that why don't
they get together and talk about it I
mean
what what's the what's the hold up with
that uh and why should
we again Pander to somebody that just
comes here and doesn't even try to go
through the
system the costs associated with the
with an SAU they have an SAU
superintendent and central office staff
basically which are maybe your special
ed staff which go out to the various
districts within maybe you have
Specialists going out too like a PE
teacher or a music teacher and those are
all underneath
SAU budget and those towns have to pay
into those those those costs which are
established by the SAU and again those
towns maybe don't have the weight of the
vote to control much of that uh you
youve been familiar with this represent
cascaden
um um I'm familiar with area agreements
yeah
um not so much Cooperative agreements so
they're a little different like we said
another animal another animal you can so
you can you know you can
accept represent
Bon um as you said uh Theus are
different in terms of each Town owns
their own buildings they own their own
property they control their own schools
the only thing that we really share is
is I believe what this bill is trying to
get at is uh the uh what the services
provided by the seu which has its own
separate budget and the the
apportionment is that that is what goes
to pay for the seu bu you know what the
the apportionment formula is like for
they have to pay is based on per pupil
or um it's the same one it's it's a
singular one that's that is in the
statute which is 50 it's based on a lot
of the co-op have it I believe it's the
50% um um according to the valuation and
the ADM
yeah and so are they looking to be able
to modify that statute from maybe 60 to
or my understanding is because they they
believe their property valuation is high
and their student population is low it
means that again their their proportion
they believe is higher than it should be
and because co-ops have the ability to
do it saus do not it's only a singular
Statute in the SAU I think that's what
the issue is yeah okay that that helps
Define
it want to go on to the next bill okay
let's go on to the next one here which
is uh 1383 relative to
Cooperative uh School Board District
elections
this is addressing some of that
discussion we've had earlier today where
they get elected by their own District
um could I hand out that previous we had
these are these are copies of that
2002 uh
Amendment um that uh
representative lad and I worked on with
um uh representative Lichfield who used
to be a member of this committee who
brought the original Bill forward and
representative abami from Ways and
Means maybe we when everybody gets this
maybe we just take an opportunity to
walk through this one right here this
amendment because it does address some
of the issues which are coming up in
these bills which we're
seeing
do you want to walk people through this
representative cordelli okay uh
um uh first of all on um the middle of
page
one um it uh goes over what the um
existing options are and we
removed that uh provision that all
members shall be elected at
large um we were trying to get away from
at large members and move as you see in
the bottom of the page to
apportionment um by uh
town of
uh uh proportional number of
Representatives so I think in my
district we looked at something to the
effect that wolfboro would have four
repres maybe wolfboro would have three
Representatives uh toughen Boro 2 and
all the rest of the the other four towns
would have one so it would be a
proportional
representation um based on
population
um um and you see that uh on over on P
page
two um it would require a transition
plan and a staggering so that you know
if you're if you were one of the atlarge
members and your term lasted for another
two terms you're not going to be kicked
off the board um so it was a a
transitional plan uh to move to the
proportional
representation um and then down at the
bottom was the um review every 10 years
so that
things could be adjusted for population
with with the
census I think those were the
main yes represent luno
yeah thanks but but didn't um didn't a a
similar Bill last year or the year
before face a
um uh face an issue with the sort of one
person one vote type of type of thing
because you've got a um a voting
district and
then if you don't have everybody in the
district being able to vote on all the
people who are running for school board
then you you ran a foul of other state
laws wasn't there something about
possibly about that but but in here you
would you would just vote on the members
from your town right but but that I
think that's exactly what the so the the
problem I think arose around where
you've got here in Roman 3 um which
she'll be elected within their own
District so
only within their own
district there there is there were those
that were oppositional to represent Norm
major was not too excited by this uh
seeing his community was would which is
basically controlling
now uh would lose some of that ability
to control the coop they had a number of
at large members that's right what was
the disposition of this bill yeah and
pardon me in 22
22 what was the disposition of this bill
wasn't it itl it it did not move forward
I I don't know if it was sted or it's
just and when and when you're talking
about the districts like in in uh make
in in 1383 talking about the the
um the pre-existing District that is now
a member of the
co-op it's not the co-op District right
right it's the pre-existing District so
the the town so to speak right yes um
and I think that's where where the where
the the um the challenge was because the
um the voting district is actually the
co-op District
the the the what what's it called the
political
body yes you're talking about the
governance of the co-op is that's a
separate entity right and then but you
have districts which are participants
within that the pre-existing districts
pre-existing those towns which came in
and joined this Co-op but when they
joined the co-op the district the
pre-existing districts no longer exist
and that the and I see I see Barrett
nodding on that the co-op district is
the political subdivision not the
pre-existing so it becomes a a a the
pre-existing districts no longer have
political subdivision status to conduct
an election I I think that's what
the what the what the what how the
discussion went on how Bill 1646 back in
2022 right but they they have they have
elections now Effingham has an election
uh tomorrow but the the problem is or
the issue is the fact that um the other
five towns can who rep can vote on who
the Effingham representative is no no I
think we're saying the same thing that
that that that all the members the
voting district is the co-op District
not the not the town of Effingham when
it comes to members on a on a qu on a
subdiv political subdivision School
Board
what's
that sorry go ahead so if I'm
understanding you correctly that would
be requiring all the co-op board members
to be elected at large which is not what
happens now
right I think but the question is that
David was relating to is that there when
these co-ops were created there was some
reason why all members of a co-op board
shall be
elected how that process my presumption
is that there was some some um
legal basis for how they currently were
recommended on how they should be
elected I would right but each articles
of agreement defines it
differently right but I think I I think
this goes more more to a a um I don't
know what you call it you know this is
an election law but sort of uh you know
it it goes to election law or
representation but but for example for
for all the people in our um represented
you know the districts we
represent um there's not some
that how do I how do you how do you say
it you I mean we all have different
numbers of constituents in our districts
depending upon how many representatives
you are in the district but you you
don't have um a representative that has
a e you know either represents a smaller
number or a larger number it's within
the voting district you all vote the
represent the same like there's four of
us in the hopkington boow district um
Muriel Angela Mel and me we all
represent the same number of of
constituents and what you'd have here is
in Roman 3 I believe is you'd have
Schoolboard representatives of a of the
co-op subdivision District that some
would be representing 300 voters some
would be representing 3,000 voters and
and so it gives you a disproportional
voice as a as a voter if uh you know if
you're from a small town
and that and you're and you're you get a
seat on the district it's just a
disproportional I mean it just I think
it I think it spills into election law
is is what I recall the the the the
challenge that we faced a couple years
ago so
Damon I don't know if this makes sense
or not but it occurs to me that there
could be a parallel to our Federal
representation that every state has two
senators regardless of the population of
the state and has a designated number of
Representatives that is based on the
population of the
state so in a way that's what the model
for the co-ops that have some members at
large and some by town it's sort of the
same as that now you're are you seeing
why you have Barrett Christina saying
this needs a commission
study uh
it it's a really heady topic and every
time you go somewhere the the rabbit
hole gets
deeper
uh so special Commission on education
and there may be some things in here
we're dealing with advisory Council for
budget and all that which we can address
but the overall structure of this thing
is very complex represent
belard thank you Mr chair I was just
going to offer a little bit of a
different view on the the issue of
representation and again I'm not an
election law exper iser but I think the
most fundamental election principle that
I know of is the principle that no
taxation without representation and as
it stands right now it seems to me that
if it's true that we have towns that are
voting overwhelmingly for you know
person X to go represent them in this
body yet they're being overruled by you
know another town who's voting for
person why it doesn't seem like we have
an issue where they're going to receive
disproportionate representation it seems
like we currently have an issue where
they have zero
representation uh and that that that
seems like the exact opposite of what we
would want to be doing
here Mr chair yes I mean no they're
they're not they their candidate may not
have been elected but they got to vote
on candidates that were running and the
people who were elected represent all
the constituents in all of the the towns
that comprise the co-ops they do have
representation it just might not be
their neighbor and I'm not disagree I'm
not saying that that's right or wrong
I'm saying that I think that's where
that's where I think the the conflict
was in maybe other parts of election law
that that we have and what
representative Damon talks about with us
that's obviously Federal and we we've I
think all heard arguments about about
you know you know you know New Hampshire
having a disproportionately large
representation in the um in the US
Senate compared to say on a per what we
got to do in about 5 minutes going to
break this thing down or a couple
minutes here uh represent cordelli is
going to direct you right now to profile
that is up uh in uh Franconia area right
there there shall be seven members of
the school board for the profile um
Co-op four members of the
profile four members of the profile
School Board should be elected by the
voters of
Bethlehem three members shall be elected
by the voters of
Lafayette so they are electing people
from their own town in that
case so that's what we were looking for
with s SP
323 and that was proportional four four
to
three okay is are there need for any
further discussion on this this has just
been an intro to Cooperative School
boards and you're walking up probably
more confused now than you've ever been
uh however um we have six bills here are
so in front of us that are we're going
to be dealing with issues associated
with the structure of school
districts co-ops in this state um I I
advise you know folks to try and read
these bills before we come up and we're
not going to be dealing with them today
uh but we will be within what I think
that they come up on Wednesday is it on
Wednesday
so uh I've asked several of the sponsors
to be here I know representative
spillsbury is here on one of them he'll
be here he's didn't come in today but he
will be here when he came in a little
earlier today we talked with him uh but
uh the sponsors will be here so when
we're talking about this I'd like to
have during that time we're discussing
this bills to maybe they can bring up
provide us a little bit more insight as
to what's going and what generated that
particular bill right R now so with that
let's take take a break right now and
we'll come back at 1:00 right do you
want to call us at 12:30 the Republicans
caucus before 1:00 um well we could
always caucus at one o' and it just take
a little bit of time prior to ready
yeah
e
going forward with these bills we have
an ad doet for uh representa clud
Welcome to our committee I didn't see
you over there John thank you very
you're more than welcome um before we
weigh down through these there um there
are some which we will not be discussing
today and so the first bill 1015 we're
waiting for an amendment on that bill
dealing with the date change so uh we
won't be discussing that today we'll do
a quickly the subsequent day um jumping
down here uh 148
we've done that that's been exec this
came over as REM as a result we had to
get the list of bills over to upstairs
by noon on that Wednesday and we did
some of these execs in the afternoon and
so we just said pile them all in on the
next go around and so that's what's been
done there
1450 um I got a mending language
provided to me yesterday from the
chancellor of the University system
that's not been written yet that's uh
dealing with the higher education and
that's the group that represent luno and
I are participating on uh looking at the
restructuring of higher education in the
state of New
Hampshire 1450 so that won't be today
either uh
1458 we've done
that uh previously and the last one 1646
we've done that
also so that leaves for today who
together
1287 and
1453 and so we're
gonna so we're going to start out with
uh
1087 we did
1418 and with 1087 I'd like to recognize
representative cordello three I moved to
itl this bill is there a
second
second represent uh motion made by
yourself represent Cordell and second by
represent
cordelli repesent cordel would you like
to speak to your motion yes thank you Mr
chair as can we hold on just one second
if we're going to get down to the point
where we know we're going down the route
of no
recommendation on these we're going to
only have one person
speaking that's been done a lot of other
committees and so that we will be able
to clear out of here quickly today so if
that happens if that happens to be one
of them represent cordel you'd be the
speaking person because you made the
motion okay thank you Mr chair you're
welcome this topic is very important to
me of information
literacy uh I actually wrote a book
about it for college students so um
that's why I wanted to speak on it now I
wanted to make sure you're clear that I
think it's very important and what is it
really fundamentally but learning how to
discern
truth so my opposition to this bill has
nothing to do with the purpose of this
commission but with the commission
itself and its
makeup
um and
I I had heard there might be an
amendment but that's I'm we're just
going with this bill that's here that uh
for
instance I feel like some of the members
of this committee would have a political
bias I also feel like the legislative
mission that comes out in lines three on
page two and line uh 10 about
legislation uh makes it a bit too
political and when you start getting
political you start having a bias which
takes away from mission of discerning
truth so um and I have a spefic specific
problem with the current bill naming on
line 13 a member of Media power youth uh
you can learn a lot about organizations
just going to their website and I won't
get into the details but there is a
political agenda to that group as there
is to the New Hampshire school library
media Association I did look at their
website last night and there are many
links to Ala American Library
Association material uh and there is no
denying that the American Library
Association does have a political agenda
and so those are my main
objections uh I think that is
all I had to say on it I also think we
have to be real careful it it does seem
like we have a lot of bills asking for a
commission on this and a commission on
that I think we need to be careful with
sort of reing that in a little thank you
represent cordelli do you you made the
the second nothing thank
you okay
um
me
you would like to speak right now
represent yeah go ahead thank you Mr
chair first of all I'd like to say that
that this bill was developed um for
positive reason not a political reason
and it was brought up because we've had
quite a bit of um discussion debate over
media what what is in libraries and this
was a bill that would hope make the
Librarians and the libraries and the
media people um having a commission uh
looking at what's happening developing
uh processes in the future um it was
meant to be a positive thing not a
political thing and um we have an
amendment uh for it that I'd like to
just say that it speaks to the two
issues that was were brought up in
committee before one about it takes
removes the media power youth
um reference in the in the uh Bill and
it also adds um what I believe
representative dry added uh which was to
have the uh report go to the chair of
the Senate and the chair of the house so
uh we tried to um appease uh what what
we heard the first time around and asked
that um something that could be positive
and could include a lot of people and U
discuss some of the issues that have
been brought up this year in the
legislature um that uh we have an OTP to
it as a result thank you very
much is there that no further discussion
here yes
represent do we have the amendment or do
we know where it is I have yes okay
thank you
okay we have a motion on the on the
table right now it's itl on 1087 that
motion was made by represent cordello
and second by representa
cordelli Madam clerk would you please
call the
RO Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
beler yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
peternell yes
representative porello yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler no representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no representative
Luna no representative cloudier uh
no Representative wock no representative
Hall no Representative bbon no
Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman lad yes
10 y 10 y okay motion
fails yes represent Tanner um I'd like
they make a motion not ought to pass
okay we have a motion made by represent
Tanner it's OTP on 1087 second by
representative Miler I'd also like to
hold on a second you got that okay uh
represent Tanner you're
recognized um I'd like to make Amendment
um 09
07h which is being passed out right
now okay let this around
okay I believe everybody should have a
copy of it right now represent Tanner
you recognize speak to your Amendment
thank you Mr chair
um was there did you put forth a motion
on on the amendment excuse me did you
put forth a motion on the I did I I
thought you had okay good um was there a
second on that same representative Miler
yes so you get that
okay go ahead represent thanks so uh as
I stated before um this amendment kind
of simplifies things a little bit uh it
removes the objection which was the uh
Media power youth
uh notice in it and also it includes uh
that the bill uh the result of the
commission's finding should go to the
speaker of the house and the president
of the Senate house clerk Senate Clerk
and the chair of the house committee and
chair of the Senate Ed ation committee
um as recommended so I think this um
kind of Tidi up the bill a little bit
and um as I said before it's it's
something that we could do that's
positive which we don't often get a
chance to
do is there uh from the second is there
no
okay represent Cordell or represent
right you both have sort of hand
swinging so I appreciate that this was
addressed about that not mentioning the
specific Media power Youth Organization
I can't recall when during the hearing I
think it was mentioned some somewhere if
anyone else can remember that this is
the only organization right now that
fulfills the requirement as now put
forth there on line 18 of the amendment
but my concern again is just getting an
organization a nonprofit organization it
seems like anytime most most
organizations today do have a political
agenda so whether that would be on
either side of the eye I believe that
brings a bias into this commission and a
bi with a bias comes that um problem of
sort of compromising on the mission of
discerning truth I just wanted to
mention that since you did address my
objection
okay doesn't look like we' have have any
more hands up
so i' just like to ask the question I
see your hand up I'd like to ask the
question that you kind of implied um
which was are there other me media
literacy organizations that serve youth
that are nonprofit educational
organizations can anybody answer that
question representative McDonald it was
said in testimony by Media power youth
that at this time they're the only
organization that meets a
requirement
okay not seeing any further hands for
discussion we have a motion on the table
it's for the amendment 0
997h OTP put forth by representa Tanner
and second by representative
Miler Madam
clerk Vice chairman cordelli
no representative luus
yes Representative beler no
representative dry no representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell no
representative Corella no representative
Terry no representative Miler
yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative claer uh yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Bon yes
representative Caden yes representative
Damon yes chairman lad yes 14 yays six
Nays
okay we have the main motion as amended
on the table right now it's hb10 187 as
amended by
I that's okay you're you're not wanting
to speak on it right no I have nothing
further okay okay uh Madam clerk would
you please call the role Vice chairman
cordel
no Representative leus no representative
Belcher no representative dry no
Representative mcdonnald no
Representative nille no Representative
peternell no Representative corello no
representative Terry no representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative claer uh yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Bon yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon
yes chairman lad no 10 y 10
Nays okay so we are looking at a no
recommendation here yes and um so
representative Tanner you'll be writing
that OTP and you'll be writing the itl
thank you OT yeah yeah otpa down there
itl
here okay
so take a break
yeah we're going to take a break here
for about five
minutes caucus break am I pronouncing
your name correctly
actually I might have done it different
ways I'm sorry I have a name like that
too so what is
it cl cl John
CL cler
okay I just know it's important to
people yeah John's been around a while
John
cluer
are
me
okay so we're now addressing 1287 this
is a relative the definition of the term
evidencebased within public education
represent beler you're recognized for a
motion thank you Mr chair I would move
off to
pass is there a second I'm a second
represent Lin seconds that
motion so beler
leus representative beler recognized as
the prime SP or maker of the motion
thank you Mr chair and we've discussed
this quite a lot so I won't belabor the
points I'll I'll just say that the the
idea of this bill is really to just to
differentiate between what represents
good science versus less good science to
make sure that we're con consistently
moving the direction of improvement and
reading out things that are not actually
properly supported by evidence the bill
places no burden on teachers because it
is not to be enforced on teachers or in
an individual classroom it is only for
those parties who are adopting methods
of education and in that it also doesn't
apply to curriculum so it's not about
what is taught but it's about how things
are taught and I think we could benefit
greatly by taking a more science-based
approach thank you is there any
discussion from the
second I just say wanted to say that my
dad being a physicist brought me up in
this and so I have too many times uh
seen people not following this CU they
don't really understand scientific
method and I was thrilled to see this
bill because this is closer to the
scientific method thank
you is there anybody else wants to speak
against repres
luno thanks very much Mr chair so um I'm
I'm disappointed that the motion coming
out of this committee would be ought to
pass to essentially turn science on its
head but I guess i' i' have to say I'm
not surprised because um seems
like half the members on this committee
feel that public schools are
failing they feel
that schools are not doing the job that
they're intended to do ref luno I I do
not believe that people feel that
everything's
failing okay well we've heard certainly
heard thank you and and I apologize Mr
chair but we've heard a number of times
um statements like that made but we
didn't hear that made by the governor
during his State of the State speech
when he said New Hampshire New
Hampshire's public schools are doing a
great job in fact they're number two as
far as student outcomes um uh across the
country and it it just it it it bothers
me so much that
that while New Hampshire public
schools are
doing a tremendous job as far as
delivering student outcomes I know it's
not happening everywhere and I know
that's we I think we all understand that
there's a number of reasons for that
that that that by and large because of
our policies and because of the support
that um that public schools have from
from our public taxpayers that um that
that it's clear that bred Staters put a
priority on student outcomes in public
education why we would want to
change how we look
at
science and turn it on its head doesn't
make any sense to me and and why would
we want to break something that's
working so well and doing so much good
for 165,000 students across the granite
state I I can I can certainly
think of reasons
why maybe stuff like this comes up but I
can't believe that that that that that's
in the best interest of public schools
or our families or our kids or our
economy so for that and for so many
other reasons I think for at least these
reasons I would be voting against the um
the ought to pass and um and hopefully
you know we we'd be able to um to defeat
this um this this this bill which um I I
would would certainly appear to
undermine um evidence and facts used in
public schools today thanks thank thank
you very much uh not going to have any
more discussion on this so we're just
going to Madam clerk we have a motion on
the table uh to OTP on
1287 would you please call the role Vice
chairman cordelli yes representative
leus
yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative petel yes representative
Coro yes representative Terry yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner no
Representative luno no representative
cluder yes representative W no sorry
sorry my gosh I I'm sorry okay
too you don't sit next to me John okay
all right okay yeah I made a mistake I I
meant to vote sorry okay
resident second time okay representative
Hall no representative bone no
Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman lad yes
10 y 10
NS do we have a motion I'll move in
expedient to legislate represent luno
makes a motion itl and second by
represent
Miler the motion's it would you like to
speak to your motion represent luno I'm
okay thank you represent uh Miler no
thank you any opposition we're right at
the vote now um so we have a motion on
the floor to itl
1287 made by represent luno second by
represent Miler Madam clerk Vice
chairman cordelli no Representative leus
no Representative beler no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative Pell no representative
Corell no representative Terry no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes repes
representative cluder yes representative
wock yes representative Hall yes
representative albone yes representative
cascaden yes representative Damon yes
chairman lad no ten
okay and and uh represent Bel you're
writing the other report okay good uh
the next bill and the last bill for
today is
1453 okay this bill is relative to
degree granting authority of certain
institutions p education represent leus
you're recognized for a
motion I'd like to move itl is there a
second second representative McDonald
makes the second so we have a motion on
table itl made by represent leus second
by representative
mcdonal represent
leus yes first off um going down through
this bill I really don't understand what
we have against having a
for-profit organization in
education I would think a for-profit
organization would do it would be much
more responsive to the students who are
their
um who are the ones using their system
and more likely to pay for so that's the
first part of it I don't understand why
we have to only be nonprofit and the
second part
is all schools everybody already needs
to follow all applicable state and
federal anti-discrimination laws it's
already in there I don't know why that's
in there either
so and I do have a question what on
Earth accreditation standards do
for-profits not have regarding you know
that what what was the point of this
bill to begin
with thank you very much from the second
well said thank
you is there anybody that wants
represent luno thank you very much Mr
chair so I think there's numerous
examples probably too many to even
discuss of uh for-profit Institutes of
higher education uh and the disservice
they do to their students the uh the the
really abysmal um uh completion rates
that they see and the uh leaving
students with enormous death debts far
exceeding those in um in um um in
nonprofit or public um U institutes so
so I one of the things New Hampshire I
think has has has been able to fend off
so far is um is for-profit institutions
none have so far been um been been
approved uh for and given degree Grant
granting Authority in the um in the
granite state and so uh so this statute
seeks to keep it that way um it also um
uh does uh does another thing that I
think is very significant and um uh and
and something that's that's actually
extraordinarily common among nonprofit
um uh Institutes of higher education
which is compliance with the Higher
Education Act of 1965 and so this is a
federal civil rights act um uh that uh
that just
about every nonprofit Institute of
higher education across the country uh
uh endorses and Embraces uh I think um
uh uh just a few years ago uh we
received a report from um from our
committee researcher Miss for um with
regards to the number of institutes that
did not and you could count them I think
on one hand uh that uh that that did not
accept um that did not comply with the
higher education act so um so so and
then of course it also puts into statute
under um under degree granting Authority
and the section that applies to to what
the standard is for that that um that
these um institutes also need to comply
with state and federal
anti-discrimination laws what that may
be in law already but the fact that we
have it here and the fact that we add
compliance with the Higher Education Act
and the fact that we codify the
requirement for them to be nonprofit I
think sets a sets a very reasonable hard
deck for um for approval of these uh
colleges for degree granting Authority
so for that reason I would oppose the
itl and support passage of the measure
thank you very much uh so at this point
in time we will call the role when
you're ready Madam clerk so we're we're
looking at
1453 and the motion on the floor is itl
in
1453 Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
elure yes representative Dr yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
peternell yes representative cor yellow
yes representative Terry yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner no
representative Luna
no Representative cluder no
Representative wock no representative
Hall no representative bon no
Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman lad yes
ten represent luno to make a motion
thank you Mr chair I'll move on to pass
there will be a motion made by represent
luno second by represent Miler for OTP
on on House Bill 1453 relative to degree
granting authority of certain
institutions of higher
education when you're ready Madam
clerk uh Vice chairman cordelli
no Representative leus no representative
Belcher no repres representative dry no
representative McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Pell no representative cello no
representative Terry no representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Lun yes representative cluder yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
no 10 y
10 who who's going to do the
report rep L has
that okay and back
you got
the yep I will I brought my okay good
thank you this is
why okay so we have no other bills for
today we're going to work on those
amendments we spoke about and so with
that we're going to close the executive
session for this afternoon thank
you
yeah
sure
because of I lost an hour I know
I I just started you know what it is I
just started putting in the wrong column
because there's three columns there's
three really okay you're GNA go make
copies that
and talk about this we can talk yeah
about this this would not have
gone there that's
so we
have